Da ist er wieder, der völlig überraschend angebrochene letzte Mittwoch im Monat, an dem hier auf Fritz-M1 passiert. Alle Leute, die normalerweise bei Fritz arbeiten, außerdem hier werden rausgeworfen und der Chaos Computer Club entert das Studio, trinkt hier seltsame Getränke, der Namen ich nicht mehr sagen darf, weil ein Kollege neulich meint, ich hätte wahrscheinlich einen Vertrag mit ihnen, baut ein komisches WLAN auf, wo man irgendwie dieses seltsame Internet kann, von dem alle reden, und erzählen dann zwei Stunden lang etwas, das mit digitalem Computernetzleben, Netzpolitik zu tun hat. All die Sachen, die heute zu Gast sind, Andreas Bog und Nibbler mit kleinem M, äh, N. Hallo und guten Abend. Und heute ist etwas passiert, das passiert tatsächlich selten bei einem Chaos Radio, weil die Leute erst mal abwarten, worum geht es denn heute, was passiert denn so. Hört man vielleicht einfach den Chaos Leuten zu, weil die erklären irgendwas und besprechen jetzt mal das Problem, aber heute, die Sendung hatte noch nicht mal angefangen. Da gab es schon Anrufer. Jetzt über das ich euch das fällt, wollen wir den jetzt gleich sozusagen erkennen lassen, worum es eigentlich geht oder wollt ihr das lieber machen? Also wenn er dann schon da ist, Richard. Guten Abend. Beim Chaos Radio angerufen, bevor die Sendung losgeht. Worum geht es heute?
Es geht um die Freiheit statt Angst Demo am 11. Nächsten Monat in Berlin.
Und was genau passiert da?
Eine Demo gegen Überwachung in jeglicher Form. Bürgerrechte, Datenschutz und jetzt ja, ich glaube zum vierten Mal.
Und du wirst mitmachen?
Ich fahre hin, ja, wie die letzten beiden Jahre auch. Weil mir das Thema echt wichtig ist. Also irgendwie mir an die Privatsphäre ist mir echt wichtig. Ich vertraue dem Staat eigentlich nicht sonderlich. Also auch der Wirtschaft auch nicht. Ich meine, es geht ja nicht nur an den Staat. Und ich ist einfach erst mal fantastisch, finde, dass es da überhaupt mal irgendwelche Demos gibt. Weil das war halt irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren noch mal anders. Oder irgendwie so 2002, 2003 saß man halt irgendwie vor seinem Computer und hat sich aufgeregt und es ist halt irgendwie überhaupt schon mal cool, dann auf eine Demo gehen zu können und einfach mal so ein paar Tausend Leute da stehen zu haben und sich irgendwo im Netz auszukotzen.
Alle zusammen aufregen in Berlin am 11. September. Das soll stattfinden. Vielen Dank, Richard. Den könnt ihr dann auf jeden Fall treffen. Und daran teilzunehmen, dazu aufgerufen hat auch der Chaos Computer Club. Und jetzt hat Richard uns gerade schon erzählt, das Ding läuft zum vierten Mal. Da ist ja wirklich die Frage, zum vierten Mal ist denn das jetzt wirklich noch notwendig? Also ich mein, da muss doch mal irgendwann ein Ende haben mit diesen ganzen Demonstrationen. Für die ganzen Sachen.
Ich hab ja gerade so ein Akustikproblem.
Vielleicht erwähne ich an dieser Stelle, falls hier so eine unnatürliche Stelle entsteht, was am Radio eigentlich eher selten ist, dann liegt es daran, dass diese Sendung gleichzeitig auch online begleitet wird. Es gibt einen Wiki zur Sendung, es gibt einen Blog zur Sendung, es gibt einen Chat zur Sendung. Und die Links dort, wie ihr dahin kommt, findet ihr unter chaosradio.chcc.de Und auch die Leute, die hier im Studio sitzen, sind da häufiger dran beteiligt und manchmal dann ein bisschen abgelenkt. Jetzt hat es angeblich am Kopfhörer gelegen, das wollen wir natürlich...
Der hier ist besser, den nehm ich jetzt.
Nicht mal abstreiten. Aber nochmal die Frage, also zum vierten Mal diese Demo, ist die wirklich noch notwendig? Also brauchen wir die noch? Oder ist das nicht sozusagen so eine Art Happening? Man macht das jetzt, weil man es jedes Jahr gemacht hat?
Na ja, irgendwie nach dem Schäuble jetzt weg ist, ist doch alles gut, oder? So ganz sehen wir das nicht. Wenn man sich anguckt, haben wir zwar immerhin eine Phase erreicht, wo Ignorieren nicht mehr geht. Und sozusagen Embrace and Extend, die Microsoft-Strategie gefahren wird seitens der Politik. Nämlich schon mit ausgestrecktem Arm auf uns zugehen und mal drüber reden und dann aber hinterher eigentlich doch dieselben Gesetze wieder beschließen wollen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Grund, warum es nach wie vor wichtig ist. Also es war, und unter Schäuble war das alles viel einfacher. Der hat sich prima als Feindbild geeignet. Da konnte man alles, also alles, was an komischen Projekten lief, direkt auf die Person projizieren. Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger geworden, aber weggegangen ist es davon alles nicht. Die Leute reden nach wie vor von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Es werden nach wie vor Swift-Daten exportiert. Wir haben eine lange Liste und Sachen, die noch aktuell sind. Ich denke, es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall noch dahin zu gehen und zum Ausdruck zu bringen, dass wir das nicht vergessen haben. Dass die Strategie, die Aufmerksamkeit, Spanne des durchschnittlichen Internet-Users so auszudehnen, dass er irgendwann das Interesse verliert, nicht funktionieren wird.
Das waren jetzt jede Menge Worte und wir wollen das heute mal zusammen tragen. Was da alles passiert auf dieser Demo oder wogegen oder vielleicht auch wofür alles demonstriert wird. Aber das schaffen wir wahrscheinlich nicht alleine, weil die Liste ist wirklich lang. Ich hab sie vorher schon mal so kurz gesehen. Das heißt, wir brauchen heute auf jeden Fall auch eure Hilfe. 0331 70 97 110 Und dann könnt ihr mal erzählen, ob ihr mit auf die Demo kommen wollt und wenn ja warum oder ob ihr euch gleich denkt, ach komm, Freiheit statt Angst. Pff, glaubt eh keiner mehr dran. Müssen wir nicht machen. So, du hast jetzt schon gerade von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesprochen. Und das ist ja wirklich ein altes Projekt. Da gab es auch schon Verfassungsgerichtsentscheide und Demonstrationen dagegen. Und das wurde doch irgendwie alles abgesägt. Was ist da eigentlich der Stand? Wieso muss man da derzeit noch dagegen demonstrieren?
Es gab ja das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes, das also die anlasslose Speicherung von Nutzerspuren erst mal untersagt hat. Es besteht aber nach wie vor das Interesse sozusagen das maximal Mögliche, was die Verfassung gerade noch erlaubt, an Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung einzuführen. Das ist, glaube ich, so die Kurzzusammenfassung. Und auch unser Innenminister mit der ausgestreckten Hand, Herr de Maizière, hält sie für fachlich zwingend und notwendig, sie umzusetzen.
Ja, aber muss man auch nicht sagen, wenn es jetzt irgendwie soweit ist, dann könnte man die doch jetzt mal einführen. Vielleicht ist es ja wirklich so, wenn die sich so lange drüber einig sind.
Na, die sind sich vielleicht mit sich selber einig, aber wir sind nicht ganz mit ihnen einig, glaube ich. Das ist der Punkt dabei. Eine Komplettüberwachung von allen eigentlich etwas ist, was abzulehnen ist. Es bestreitet ja keiner, dass es Strafverfolgung auch im Internet geben muss. Es gibt durchaus Fälle, da muss man mal rauskriegen, wer der Böse war. Aber es gibt ja auch andere Wege, das zu erreichen. Das Wort, was da immer viel genannt wird, ist der Quick Freeze. Das heißt, wenn was passiert, sagt man halt Bescheid, ruft eine Hotline an. Die kümmert sich dann darum, dass gerade Diensthabende, Staatsanwalt, man braucht ja bloß einen deutschlandweit, der immer Dienst hat, 24-7, dass der halt beschließt, die Daten müssen jetzt mal drei Tage gespeichert werden beim Provider. Und dann hat man ausreichend Zeit, einen ordentlichen Antrag zu schreiben und das über den Schreibtischstand des Richters zu schieben und die persönlichen Daten rauszudrücken. Aber das Anlasslosen grundsätzlich für alle zu tun, ist etwas, was nach wie vor einfach abzulehnen ist.
Jetzt ist es ja so, es gibt aber derzeit keine konkreten politischen Pläne, sondern es ist so, das wird mal immer wieder gesagt, man könnte ja vielleicht, oder es ist ja vielleicht eine gute Idee, kann man ja wirklich dann noch dagegen demonstrieren, oder muss man nicht dann eigentlich vielleicht schon sagen, mit Gegenvorschlägen auf die Demo gehen und sagen, Quick Freeze für alle, oder wie auch immer man das dann formuliert. Eine weitere Möglichkeit, wo ihr anrufen könnt, falls euch coole Demos, Demos-Slogans einfallen, oder ihr ein witziges T-Shirt zum Vorschlag habt, bitte auch 0331 70 97 110. Aber jetzt nochmal, geht denn sozusagen das Dagegen demonstrieren wirklich noch, oder müsste man vielleicht dann mal was anderes mit auf die Demo bringen?
Also die Hauptaussage ist glaube ich, dass die ganzen Dinge, die da beschlossen werden, ein großer Teil davon eben nicht alternativlos ist. Dass es da durchaus andere Möglichkeiten gibt und dass man als Betroffener davon das durchaus anders sieht. Was Leute dir jetzt sagen, okay wir wollen jetzt erstmal die ganzen Daten, damit wir da bequemer arbeiten können. Da gibt es durchaus Alternativen dazu.
Man darf halt einfach auch nicht auf diesen Wir sind dagegen verharren. Ich denke, das ist ganz wichtig. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die jetzt passieren muss. Dass man sagt, was sind denn die Probleme, die in Anführungszeichen, die da oben lösen wollen? Und was sind denn die Wege, diese Probleme anständig und vernünftig zu lösen? Also wir haben sie glaube ich ausreichend weit mit dem Rücken an die Wand gedrängt, dass sie mittlerweile drauf dran sind zu sagen, na gut, da sagt doch mal, was wir machen sollen. Zumindest teilweise drängt sich der Eindruck auf. Immer kann man dem natürlich nicht trauen, aber auf jeden Fall steht man dann auch in der Debatte verloren da. Wenn man bloß sagt dagegen und dann irgendwie die Frage kommt, na ja, wie wird es denn dann? Was ist denn die Alternative zu unserem alternativen Flussenvorschlag? Kann man ja nicht sagen, irgendwie nicht machen. Also nicht machen ist natürlich auch immer noch eine Alternative zu machen. Also alternativlos ist nie wirklich wahr. Man kann es auch einfach lassen. Aber viele Sachen haben auch Lösungen, wo wir mittlerweile schon aufgefordert sind, auch mit eigenen Lösungen zu kommen.
Und die bringt auch die Demo mit oder wird die Demo dann eher noch mal so ein Bashing, wie es so schön heißt?
Na ja, wie gesagt, die optisch attraktiven Feindbilder wurden ja abgeschafft. Insofern, wir haben halt auch nicht für alles Antworten. Das ist alles noch nicht fertig. Sonst könnten wir gleich sagen, wir schmeißen den Laden ab morgen.
Das wäre doch auch mal eine Idee, oder nicht?
Na ja, so mal zur Abwechslung. Was willst denn du für ein Mindestthema haben?
Hier Vergnügen und Hedonismus. Oder gibt es das noch nicht?
Ich fürchte, das gibt es noch nicht.
Dann müssen wir das natürlich sofort schaffen. Falls ihr auch noch Ideen habt, welche Ministerien geschaffen werden sollen, falls der Chaos Computer Club die Welt übernimmt, oder zumindest erstmal Deutschland, dann könnt ihr anrufen. Aber es geht heute eigentlich um die Freiheit und Angst-Demo. Die findet am 11. September statt. Und wir wollen mal die ganzen Themen, die es da gibt, weil es gibt anscheinend sozusagen nicht nur das eine, weswegen diese Demonstration eigentlich mal gegründet wurde, nämlich Vorratsdanspeicherung. Mittlerweile hat sich da ganz schön viel angesammelt und es gibt nicht nur Themen, gegen die demonstriert wird, es gibt auch Themen, die direkt mit der Demonstration zu tun haben. Also ich sag mal die Schlagwörter Videoaufzeichnung, Polizeikennzeichnung. Da wollen wir auch noch drüber reden. All das heute hier im Chaosradio. Wir machen jetzt aber erstmal eine ganz kleine Musik, auch passend zum Thema und sind dann gleich wieder bei euch. Es gibt so feste Größen hier beim Chaosradio. Einer davon ist, wenn Musik gespielt wird, ist im zugehörigen ELC-Channel, wo ihr zur Sendung chatten könnt, tierisches Gemecker am Start. Das ist wirklich immer so, egal was man macht. In diesem Fall können wir allerdings unsere Hände total in Unschuld waschen, denn diese Musik, die von den Marvels kommt und auf den Namen, einen kleinen Moment muss ich mal nachschlagen, hört, Vounded Seriously, wurde sich gewünscht im Wiki zur Sendung, wo ihr nämlich immer vor der Sendung eintragen könnt, welche Creative-Commons-Musik hören wollt und das war wie gesagt jemand, der dann das Wiki geschrieben hat und wenn es nicht passt, dann macht es gefälligst selber besser. Außerdem steht eine feste Größe auch die Demonstration Freiheit statt Angst, die jedes Jahr stattfindet und über die wir heute hier beim Chaosradio reden wollen. Wir haben gerade schon auch darüber geredet, dass es nicht nur Themen gibt, über die in der Demo gesprochen werden soll oder die für die die Demo Aufmerksamkeit erregen soll, sondern es gibt auch Themen, die direkt auf der Demo spielen. Das eine ist Videoüberwachung direkt vor Ort und durch die Polizei. Da gibt es ja einmal die Überwachung durch die Polizei, dann die Gegenüberwachung und dann gab es noch einen Rechtsstreit. Vielleicht können wir einen kleinen Einblick haben, wie der aktuelle Stand mit den Videokameras auf der Demo aussieht und wer welche wann tragen kann oder soll.
Ja, an den Videokameras ist ja quasi genau die Antwort auf die Überwachung, die wir vorhin schon mit dem Quick Freeze hatten. Nämlich, also es kam da Kritik von wegen, aber wenn doch die Demonstranten dann auch Videokameras mitbringen, dann ist das ja auch Überwachung. Nö, das ist eben genau nicht, sondern wenn es wirklich den Fall gibt, dass da sich Leute prügeln, wie auch immer die gerade gekleidet sind, dann mit der Videokamera drauf zu halten, das ist quasi genau der Gegenvorschlag, den man da in Form des Quick Freezes bringt in der Realität.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man noch ein bisschen für alle, die noch nicht dabei waren, die Geschichte erzählen, die sich dazu getragen hat. Also das ging schon bei den ersten Demos los, dass die Polizei die Teilnehmer gefilmt hat, was natürlich auf einer Demo gegen Überwachung besonders pikant ist. Und zwar nicht nur, wenn irgendwelche Straftaten passiert sind, sondern auch anlasslos, also grundlos. Es wurden alle abgefilmt. Wir haben ja auch in Deutschland die Besonderheit des Vermohmungsverbotes auf Demonstrationen. Das heißt, man muss sein Gesicht auch zeigen und landet dann auf einem Videoband. Es gab da ein bisschen Streit darüber. Das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin hat entschieden, dass es nicht zulässig ist, verdachtlos auf Demos zu filmen, dass also eine Straftat stattfinden oder unmittelbar bevorstehen muss, damit die Polizei filmen darf. Der Herr Gliedsch, unser Polizeipräsident, sieht das nicht ein und hat erstmal Berufung eingelegt. Und wir werden also davon ausgehen müssen, dass die Berliner Polizei uns filmen wird gegen den Richterspruch des Verwaltungsgerichtes. Das ist die eine Seite. Und dann haben Demos, insbesondere in Berlin, auch immer so gewisse Begleiterscheinungen. Das Publikum, das auf diese Freiheit statt Angst-Demo kommt, ist ja ein sehr, sehr gemischtes und sehr, sehr breites. Das ist also das rangiert von Ärzten bis zu Punks, von jungen Liberalen bis zu den Marxisten, Leninisten. Und natürlich gibt es da auch Leute, die auf anderen Protestformen dann auch mal anfangen, mit Dingen um sich zu werfen. Etwas, was wir auf unserer Demo eigentlich gar nicht haben wollen. Die Leute kommen trotzdem, sind auch so lange willkommen, wie sie das mit dem Werfen bleiben lassen. Das haben sie bislang auch immer sehr gut geschafft. Das Team, das sich nicht so richtig an den Spielregeln gehalten hat, beim letzten Mal waren allerdings die Jungs in Grünen, die Polizei, die nämlich dann am Ende der Demo tatsächlich noch angefangen haben, Leute zu verhaften mit dem Hinweis auf Verstoß gegen das Vermummungsverbot. Und dann kam es also zu Diskussionen. Und im Rahmen dieser Diskussion kam es zu einem Zwischenfall, bei der ein Demonstrationsteilnehmer von der Polizei sehr, sehr unsandt festgenommen wurde, sodass er sich ins Krankenhaus begeben musste und sich behandeln lassen. Also mit mehrfachen Schlägen ins Gesicht und dem Herausreißen der halben Lippe. Und sehr unangenehm. Und was für die Polizei unangenehm war, war, dass dieser Vorfall auf Video dokumentiert wurde durch ein Mitglied des Chaos Computer Clubs in ausgesprochen hochauflösend. Und die Polizei also anfing, auch Herr Glitsch anfing sich in Widersprüche zu verstricken, was denn da passiert ist. Und nachdem sie sich also eine Erklärung zurechtgelegt hatten und die in eine Presseerklärung getan haben, warum es total die Schuld des Demonstranten war, direkt in die Faust gelaufen zu sein, gab es dann plötzlich eine zweite Videoaufnahme, die genau diese Geschichte widerlegte. Was also so weit ging, dass eine einstweilige Verfügung erlassen wurde gegen den Polizeipräsidenten, dass er nicht weiter behaupten darf, dass der entsprechende Demonstrant gewalttätig geworden wäre oder sich den Anweisungen der Polizeibeamten widersetzt hätte. Und im Rahmen dieser Geschichte ist auch die Debatte um die Kennzeichnungspflicht der Polizei wieder hochgekommen. Das heißt, wenn ich als Bürger auf eine Demonstration, eine Straftat begehe, dann wird das auf Video aufgezeichnet. Ich werde verhaftet und lande dafür für Gericht. Und wenn ich als Staatsbürger in Uniform auf einer Demonstration, eine Straftat begehe, dann gab es bislang eine Kultur des Wegschauens. Das hat viele Jahrzehnte lang funktioniert. Ich habe von Leuten gehört, die waren damals in Wackersdorf dabei. Da war das natürlich auch schon so. Und da gab es aber noch keine digitalen HD-Kameras. Und die gibt es jetzt. Und so hat sich das Spiel auch ein bisschen geändert. Das war, glaube ich, der erste Fall, in dem es tatsächlich so dicht und lückenlos dokumentiert werden konnte, was da passiert ist.
Aus mehreren Perspektiven.
Und das ist halt etwas, was schwierig wegzudiskutieren ist, was aber leider immer noch nicht zu strafrechtlichen Konsequenzen geführt hat für die entsprechenden Beamten. Was immer noch nicht dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Kennzeichnungspflicht umgesetzt wird. Und das ist natürlich hochgradig bedauerlich. Da werden wir so ein bisschen sehen, was auf der Demo passiert. Und wir können nur alle auffordern, Kameras mitzubringen. Und wenn euch was komisch vorkommt und Leute anfangen, sich anzuschreien, und manche davon haben eine Uniform an, andere nicht, dann vielleicht mal einzufangen zu fehlen.
Wie ist denn der Stand mit dem Typen ausgegangen? Ist er sozusagen völlig freigesprochen? Und man weiß jetzt nicht genau, was mit dem Polizisten passiert oder wie?
Ich glaube, da gibt es tatsächlich noch kein Ergebnis. Es gab natürlich dann gegen den Stranden eine Anzeige wegen Widerstandes gegen die Staatsgewalt und Landfriedensbruchs. Da scheint bei der Polizei auch so eine Art, wenn du mich ärgerst, ärgere ich dich zurück zu existieren. Also wenn man sie nach einer Dienstnummer fragt, was da ganz offensichtlicher Fall war, dann bekommt man halt aufs Maul und wird mitgenommen, wenn man das beim nächsten Mal nicht nochmal macht. Und wenn man es wagt, einen Beamten anzuzeigen, hat man sofort eine Gegenanzeige. Und in der Regel geht das halt so aus, da sagen halt vor Gericht drei Beamte übereinstimmend aus. Und dann hat man als Zivilist natürlich ein Problem dagegen zu argumentieren, weil Aussage steht gegen Aussage und drei Beamte sind mehr wert als ein Bürger. Also wird das fallen gelassen.
Dazu sei im Vorhinein der Vortrag am 26C3 war das, glaube ich. Da gibt es auch ein Recording von, wenn ich mich da richtig erinnere, wo das nochmal genau zum Thema war, inklusive der Videos.
Da kann man also sich alles nochmal genau angucken. Und wenn ihr am 11. September zur Freiheit statt Angst-Demo kommen wollt, dann packt ihr bitte eine Kamera rein. So, wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach wollen wir uns mal mit den ganzen Themen beschäftigen, die auf der Demonstration dieses Jahr eventuell eine Rolle spielen werden. Wir hören uns also gleich wieder. Heute Chaos Radio mit Markus Richter und mit Andreas Bog und Nibler mit einem N von Chaos Computer Club. Tach. Und die sind heute hier, um mal darüber zu sprechen oder aufzuklären, je nachdem wie man sehen will, ob die Demo-Freiheit statt Angst, die am 11. September stattfinden soll, tatsächlich noch notwendig ist. Die Ansage war schon ja selbst Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein Thema, das schon auf der ersten Demo-Rolle gespielt hat, sei immer noch aktuell, weil sich viele Politiker noch nicht so ganz von der Idee verabschiedet haben. Dann haben wir gerade darüber gesprochen, wie man sich auf der Demo selber verhalten kann. Die Ansage war, man solle doch bitte eine Kamera mitbringen, um so zu gucken, was die Staatsgewalt da so treibt, und auch immer am Start zu haben, ob sie sich gut benimmt oder nicht.
Da hatte ich gerade noch einen Sicherheitshinweis zum Thema Kamera.
Einen Sicherheitshinweis, na dann?
Einen Sicherheitshinweis zum Thema Kamera. Und zwar, wenn irgendwas passiert und ihr so ein Video habt, dann tut das nicht einfach auf YouTube. Nehmt euch entweder die Zeit, die Gesichter zu verpixeln, weil es geht auch da wieder um den Datenschutz, im Zweifelsfall um Opferschutz, um Schutz der Identität der Unbeteiligten. Und noch besser eigentlich zu den zuständigen Anwälten oder zum EA, dem Ermittlungsausschuss, den es auf jeder guten Demo geben wird. Und ja, weiterhin haben wir auch noch einen Demoradgeber.
Sarah hat nämlich angerufen, hätte glaube ich genau dazu eine Frage.
Ja, hallo, nein, ich habe dazu keine Frage, sondern eher ein Hinweis. Und zwar, wenn du selber als Demonstrant auf einer Demonstration filmst und du wirst jetzt selber festgenommen, dann sind es ja auf dem Band, auf dem Film ist ja Material drauf. Und wenn die Polizei das dann sich anguckt, dann kann es halt passieren, dass dann Sachen darauf sind, die andere Menschen belasten. Deswegen hab ich mir sagen lassen, dass es gar nicht gut ist, Kameras beziehungsweise irgendwas zum Film auf einer Demonstration mitzunehmen, beziehungsweise überhaupt zu filmen. Also man sollte halt irgendwie, das ist das, was man mir gesagt hat, am besten aufgrund von Überwachungstechniken sowas wie Handy oder Kamera zu Hause leisten. Also Handy auch wegen den Bewegungen. Also das kann halt auch überwacht werden durch das Handy.
Das hängt meines Erachtens ein bisschen von der Aktionsform ab, die man da vor hat zu wählen und die Freiheit statt Angst ist also mit explizit eine friedliche Demonstration. Wir gehen da keine Straftaten, wir haben es vier Jahre lang geschafft, dass wir keine Straftaten begangen haben, sondern dass die Polizei Straftaten begangen hat. Und wenn das so bleibt, dann... Also es gibt durchaus Situationen, wo du Recht hast, da sollte man keine Kameras mitnehmen und auch keine Telefone und am besten gar nichts, aber ich glaube, bei dieser spezifischen Demo ist der Fall ein bisschen anders.
Ja, das Ding ist ja auch, die Polizei ist ja auch daran interessiert, dass es nicht nur konkret um Straftaten geht, sondern überhaupt auch Menschen zu beobachten, die überhaupt auf Demos gehen, also ein bisschen auszuspionieren.
Aber die filmen doch eh schon die ganze Zeit. Ich kann mich da an mehrere Kameratroops erinnern, an mehrere Mobile. Es gibt immer dieses Auto mit dem Mast obendrauf, wo auch sehr weitreichende Kameras da sind. Die filmen auch. Und das ist einfach, ich denke, an der Zeit zurückzufilmen.
Außerdem ist es doch höchst verdächtig, wenn du kein Telefon dabei hast. Das ist ja beinahe schon ein konspiratives Verhalten.
Ernsthaft, die Argumentation gab es mal. Ja.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Konspiratives Verhalten. Da das Telefon ja geträgt wird, und wenn du also vorhast, dich eine Straftat zu verabreden, dann lässt du dein Handy zu Hause. Und sich also mit jemanden zu treffen und sein Handy zu Hause zu lassen, wird als konspiratives Verhalten interpretiert und ist im Zweifelsfall strafferschärfend. Ja, natürlich ist das Quatsch.
Es gibt Leute, die haben auch kein Handy, denen ist das geklaut worden oder haben sie verloren oder haben sie zu Hause vergessen.
Ich wollte jetzt auch mal sagen, ist das sozusagen eine Anekdote, die man sich erzählt, die mal passiert ist? Oder ist das sozusagen die Regel?
Das war im Fall von Andre Heum der Punkt, der ihm negativ ausgelegt wurde, dass er manchmal sein Telefon aus hätte, wenn er sich mit Leuten trifft und dass das ja wohl konspiratives Verhalten sei. Also da gibt es durchaus ein Real-World-Beispiel.
Aber hat er das Bestand?
Das Verfahren wurde eingestellt wegen 129a. Du weißt, wie das ist mit 129a-Verfahren.
Das ist, na, okay, ich ja und der Rest nicht. Deswegen geht's erklären.
Ach so, naja, die werden in der Regel eingestellt. Also in der Regel sind 129a-Ermittlungsverfahren lediglich dazu da Aufklärung, Spionage zurechtfertigen. Die führen in den seltensten Fällen zu einer Verurteilung.
Okay, kommen wir jetzt zurück zur Kamera auf der Demo. Nehmen wir jetzt mit oder nicht? Doch, ne, deutlich dafür, deutlich dafür.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Geht vielleicht vorher noch mal die Bilder, die da schon drauf sind, runter machen, weil wenn einem das Ding doch auf die ein oder andere Form abhanden kommt, dann will man da schon die Privatsphäre der Leute, die man damit fotografiert hat. Also mit einem frischen Stick und einer Kamera.
Saubere Kamera mitnehmen, Telefon dabei haben, sonst trifft man sich konspirativ. Das finde ich wirklich großartig.
Sarah, wie siehst du bis jetzt? Also, weiß ich nicht. Ich bin da ein bisschen unsicher. Ich kann sowohl die eine Argumentation als auch die andere verstehen.
Was mich jetzt interessieren würde, ist, wo hast du das denn gehört, dass man diese Argumentation, dass man Kameras nicht mitnehmen soll?
Ich glaube, das war irgendwie auch so ein Demuratgeber. Was tun, wenn es brennt, heißt er, glaube ich. Ich habe das schon so häufig irgendwie auch. Auch Leute haben mir das erzählt. Ich bin ja schon länger aktiv, gehe auf Demonstrationen.
Ich glaube, das hört sich in der Tat nach Demonstrationen an, wo sozusagen geplant wird.
Nein, überhaupt nicht, gar nicht. Das ist wirklich so generell. Generell wirklich.
Ich bin ja jetzt auch nicht der Mensch, der anfängt, hier mit Steinen zu schmeißen. Ich bin ja auch friedlich. Und ich will natürlich auch, dass so eine Demonstration friedlich abläuft.
Also sprich doch diese Videoaufnahmen, die bei der Polizei überlassen.
Nein.
Ich will gar nicht, dass da geschehen wird.
Das wäre natürlich auf aller Geilsten, aber das funktioniert leider nicht.
Ich fürchte, das machen die nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt irgendwie der richtige Weg ist, zu sagen, dann filmen wir halt auch. Wenn die halt filmen so, bin ich mir doch unsicher, ob das jetzt irgendwie dann...
Also dieses Beispiel aus der Verletzten-Demeration war ja so, es gab da tatsächlich Videoaufnahmen von der Polizei, von dem Fall, die haben nur sozusagen zur passenden Gelegenheit, also wenn es wirklich interessant wurde, weggeschwenkt, dass da nachgewiesen werden konnte, dass der Typ sozusagen nichts gemacht hat. Das war nur wegen der Privataufnahmen.
Das ist auch möglicherweise einfach nur für jetzt unter den Umständen gesehenen Glücksfall gewesen, dass es gerade dann in dem Fall gefilmt wurde oder so. Aber wenn man das jetzt zu regeln lässt, glaube ich, kann da auch ganz viel schiefgehen.
Aber was denn konkret?
Na ja, eben was ich schon sagte. Du kannst halt auch Sachen filmen, wo die Polizei jetzt gerade nicht drauf hält. Und dann wirst du festgenommen. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass die jetzt irgendwie überall ihre Augen haben oder ihre Kameras. Und dass sie jedes kleine Fittlichchen dann auch filmen. Und wenn du halt dann gerade was zufälligerweise drauf hast, was dann irgendwie bei einer Festnahme doch verwertbar ist, dann ja. Oder sei es einfach nur diese Spionage-Geschichten.
Unser Punkt ist ja nicht auszuspionieren und sich da irgendwie eine lückenlose Videoüberwachung der kompletten Demo zu haben, die ins Archiv zu legen, sondern einfach das Ding dabei zu haben, dass wenn wirklich was passiert, man da draufhalten kann. Das ist ja genau das, was uns da von der Totalüberwachung absetzt.
Vielleicht sollte man auch einfach sich überlegen, ob man jemand ist, der im Zweifelsfall filmt und dann abhaut, oder ob man jemand ist, der sich im Zweifelsfall auch verhaften lässt.
Ja, aber gut, das kann es ja nicht immer. Wenn du eingekesselt wirst oder so, kannst du das ja nicht immer irgendwie vorausklaren.
Das ist richtig.
Kleiner Tipp für die Demovorbereitung, Speicherregel weitwurfüben.
Okay, Sarah, dir auf jeden Fall erstmal vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ich glaube, grundsätzlich werden wir das jetzt in der Tat nicht mehr klären können, weil die Angst kann ja keiner so richtig nehmen.
Das ist auch zu ein kontroverses Thema. Es gibt natürlich auch Risiken dabei, das muss man so sehen, aber letztes Jahr hat es gut funktioniert.
Und deswegen wollt ihr zumindest es sozusagen auch weiter so versuchen. Noch mal zurück zu dem, was mache ich dann eigentlich mit den Aufnahmen, wenn ich die habe? Das heißt, wenn ich sie, ihr habt ja gesagt, im Gesicht verpixeln, das gilt aber nur, wenn ich es ins Netz stellen will, oder wie?
Das ist richtig. Man sollte dafür sorgen, dass die Videoaufnahmen dann den Anwälten der Opfer zugehen. Das aber unverpixelt? Das natürlich unverpixelt. Veröffentlichen ist immer kritisch, da gab es auch schon Probleme. Leute, die ihre selbst gedrehten Videos von der Demo veröffentlicht haben und dann von der Polizei Besuch bekommen haben, das kann unangenehm sein. Einerseits gibt es den Aspekt, andererseits gibt es natürlich auch den Aspekt, dass es ja eine Datenschutzdemo ist und dass es eigentlich genau gar nicht geht, dass wir uns nicht an Datenschutzgrundsätze halten bei solchen Geschichten.
Also ok, jetzt mal so sagen, weil auf der Demo passieren noch andere Dinge, als das da dort im Kamerad rumlaufen. Ich versuche mal kurz zusammenzufassen und ihr sagt dann, ob ich richtig liege. Also Ansicht ist, Kameras mitnehmen, dann nur filmen, wenn die Polizei was Böses macht. Das nicht einfach ungeschmieden ins Netz stellen, sondern an die Leute weitergeben, die damit was anfangen können. Und vorher die privaten Bilder löschen, die drauf sind. Soweit so gut?
Genau.
Weil das sozusagen, eure Meinung nach, die einzige Chance ist, dass man...
Es ist vor allem auch eine Ansage, dass, wenn es da Probleme in die Richtung gibt, wir damit durchaus umgehen können. Und vielleicht die Hoffnung, dass es dieses Jahr seitens der Polizei etwas friedlicher und defensiver als beim letzten Mal läuft.
Das hoffen wir auch. Mal gucken, was der Benjamin... Der heißt nämlich, als ich das Thema abschließen wollte, angerufen, willst du auch noch was dazu sagen. Benjamin, warum jetzt erst?
Ich hab's schlecht verstanden, sorry.
Warum, wo du jetzt erst anrufst? Wir reden doch schon seit 3000 Stunden über das Thema.
Weil ich aus dem Kino gerade gekommen bin und ich gerade Fritz eingeschaltet hab.
Okay, guter Mann. Was ist jetzt deine Meinung zum Film? Was ist deine Meinung zur Demo? Willst du hingehen oder nicht?
Also wie ich schon eben schon gesagt habe, wenn ich die Zeit dazu habe und finde, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall zur Demo hingehen. Erst das bin ich auf kleineren Demoveranstaltungen und ich bin eigentlich dafür, dass von beiden Seiten ausgefilmt wird. Ich sag mal, wir leben in Anführungsstrichen heute im Überwachungsstaat. Jeder möchte sich auch für seine Seite absichern und von daher sehe ich es so, dass die Polizei sich gerne da absichern darf, aber auch der Demonstrant sich absichern soll.
Okay, wir gucken uns alle gegenseitig ins Gesicht und hauen uns nicht. Würde zu sagen. Wir gucken uns alle gegenseitig ins Gesicht und schlagen uns dafür nicht.
Also ich sag mal, so eine Demo ist ja nun immer was Friedliches eigentlich, wenn es nicht wirklich ausatmet. Und von daher denke ich mal, um sich trotzdem irgendwo bei so einer Demo abzusichern, sollte man das filmen.
Okay, und du sagst, du wirst hingehen, wenn du die Zeit findest. Das hört sich jetzt nicht so an, als ob das derbe wichtig ist.
Nee, das Problem ist, dass ich seit langem endlich mal Urlaub habe und den wenn auch genießen will.
Ahja, und da zählt zur Demo gehen nicht dazu, das ist eher so unangenehme Arbeit.
Nee.
Oder bist du einfach nicht in der Stadt?
Ach, das wird schönes Wetter sein. Ich bin in Mallorca und von daher, wenn ich den Flug kriege.
Das lassen wir als Ausrede gerade noch gelten. Warum gehst du denn hin, wenn du nicht in Mallorca bist?
Ja, ich sag mal, das ist halt wieder dieser Oberbegriff. Warum geht man zu einer Demo, um irgendwo was zu tun, sage ich mal, in Anführungsstrichen.
Ja genau, aber sozusagen zu tun wogegen. Also das Ding ist ja, wir haben heute schon versucht anzureißen, da gibt es ganz viele Themen. Die Frage ist sozusagen, aus welchem konkreten Grund gehst du hin? Oder gehst du nur darauf hin, weil du vertraust, die Veranstalter werden schon recht haben? Und da gehen wir jetzt einfach mal mit, weil irgendwie ist super.
Naja, auf diesem Thema Veranstalter haben immer recht das Ofen Zwiespalt für mich. Weil man findet für sich immer irgendwelche Eckpunkte an einer Demo, wo man sagt, ja das finde ich gut. Und ich denke immer, dass ich zu der Demo gehen würde, weil ich halt, wie ich schon gesagt habe, zeigen möchte, ja, ich fühle mit in Anführungsstrichen und will zeigen, dass was getan wird.
Aber sozusagen genau über einzelne Themen bist du nicht informiert, sondern vertraust dann darauf, dass das da passiert? Okay, wir haben jetzt hier eine Liste von vielen Sachen. Sag mal eine Zahl, eine kleine Zahl, also irgendwas unter zehn. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht. Die elektronische Gesundheitskarte steht auf der Liste, die wir ein bisschen vorbereitet haben. Darüber werden wir jetzt gleich mal sprechen. Vielen Dank, Benjamin. Und tschüss. So, wie gesagt, heute hier sollt ihr ja mal ein bisschen auch erklären, warum diese Demo überhaupt noch sinnvoll sein könnte, was für Themen es da noch gibt. Ihr habt vorher so eine kleine Liste vorbereitet, so eine Stichwortliste. Darunter steht jetzt auch zahlenmäßig ausgewählt von Benjamin die elektronische Gesundheitskarte. Das ist auch so ein Thema, das hab ich seit gefühlten 3000 Jahren nicht mal auf dem Schirm, weil ich dachte, das ist irgendwann mal geplant worden, dann wollte das keiner und das war sowieso doof. Und jetzt sollen wir dann wieder gegen demonstrieren.
Warum? Die elektronische Gesundheitskarte ist ein bisschen komplexes Thema. Auf jeden Fall war sie, der Ärzteverband war ja da auf den letzten Demos und hat mit uns mit demonstriert. Und die hatten da diverse Befürchtungen, die damit zu tun haben, dass da der Datenschutz auch den Bach runtergeht, wenn alles zentral gespeichert wird, grob gesprochen. Und das Problem bei der EGK ist aber, dass das mit dem Datenschutz jetzt eigentlich schon kaputt ist. Dass also die Daten jetzt schon auf Papier an die Krankenkassen weitergereicht werden. Also das Problem ist bei der EGK tatsächlich nicht weniger die technische Umsetzung als elektronische Karte. Also abgesehen davon, dass es unheimlich viel Geld kostet, genau gar nichts bringt und auch die Sicherheit nicht wirklich erhöhen wird. Aber davon abgesehen von dieser Milliarde oder den drei, ist es jetzt schon so, dass die Krankenkassen jede Menge Daten bekommen. Dass also in den Krankenkassen zentral gespeichert wird, wer welche Krankheit hat, weil die Ärzte das weitermelden. Und wenn man halt irgendwie seinem Arzt im Vertrauen erzählt, irgendwie man es schwul und nimmt ab und zu Drogen, dann ist der eigentlich verpflichtet, die entsprechenden ICD-10-Klassifizierung... Bitte was?
Was sind ICD-10-Klassifizierungen?
Das ist sozusagen die medizinische Kategorie für die Risikogruppe, in der du dich befindest. Ich glaube, schwul wurde tatsächlich abgeschafft. Aber sowas wie masochistisch gibt es noch. Oder diverse Arten der Paraphilie, F65 ist das. Und das schreibt er dann da drauf und schickt das an die Krankenkasse. Weil das ist Gesetzeslage. Also für jede Krankheit, die du hast, gibt es so einen Code. Und der Code kommt auf den Zettel und das wird in die Krankenkasse geschickt.
Aber die Argumentation ist doch wahrscheinlich, die Krankenkasse bezahlt schließlich die Behandlung. Deswegen muss sie auch wissen, was sie bezahlt.
Genau das ist die Argumentation. Also es wird dann immer gesagt, naja, man muss doch wissen, was die Leute haben. Und da muss doch Betrug verhindert werden. Und die bösen Ärzte, die beuten uns aus. Also die Ärzte und die Krankenkassen, die mögen sich auch immer gegenseitig nicht. Und diese EGK, da wurde ein relativ aufwendiges System darum gezimmert, den Status Quo zu erhalten in einer Welt, wo die sich gegenseitig nicht trauen. Und das Problem ist, datenschutzttechnisch ist das Kind eigentlich schon auf dem Papier in den Brunnen gefallen. Das ist auch noch gar nicht so lange her. Das ist jetzt irgendwie vier Jahre her, die Gesundheitsreform, drei oder vier Jahre, seit der das so ist. Und also der Protest gegen die EGK kann eigentlich auch bloß ein Protest, aus Datenschutzsicht, ein Protest gegen die schon existierende Datenwettergabe im Gesundheitswesen sein.
Das heißt, wenn man da jetzt einen Poster bastelt, dann kann man da gleich mal gegen die ganze derzeitige Datenwettergabe im Gesundheitswesen demonstrieren. Apropos Poster, wir haben ja noch keine anderen von dir mit coolen Demo-Sprüchen. Auch aus den letzten Jahren könnten wir die gerne mal zusammentragen, da gab es ein paar lustige Dinge dabei. Und außerdem, der Innenminister, eignet sich eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr als Feindbild, oder könnte man da schon wenigstens einen oder anderen Spruch machen?
Der ist schon relativ Teflonbeschichtet.
Vielleicht kann man daraus ja was machen. Ok, die elektronische Gesundheitskarte haben wir dann also. Was das eigentlich, das hat mich so interessiert, gibt es eigentlich eine Meinung der Datenschützer auf der Demo, also sozusagen eine einstimmige Meinung zur Street View?
Ich glaube, eine einstimmige Meinung gibt es nicht, aber es gibt schon so eine Tendenz. Und die Tendenz ist klar, wenn da irgendwie Menschen oder Fahrzeuge auf diesen Bildern drauf sind, dann gehören die verpixelt, weil keiner beim Puffbesuch von Google fotografiert werden möchte. Aber letzten Endes gibt es ja klassisch die Panoramafreiheit. Ich kann einfach irgendwo hingehen und von einem Haus ein Foto machen, wenn ich auf öffentlichem Straßenland stehe und darf das und darf das auch veröffentlichen. Und das sozusagen Streetview zu untersagen ist schon eine Abkehr von der gängigen Praxis. Und ich finde auch nicht, dass Hausfassaden so das Problem sind, über das man sich Gedanken machen muss, wenn man auf der anderen Seite die Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat, die Weitergabe der Swift-Daten, die Arbeitnehmer-Daten-Erfassung, den elektronischen Personalausweis, jetzt lese ich die Themen einfach alle mal.
Wenn euch was davon gefällt und ihr im Näheres dazu wissen wollt, dann macht ihr nämlich einfach folgendes.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 So, was fehlt noch?
Volkszählung war das letzte, was du gesagt hattest?
Ja, ich glaube, dann sind wir auch durch. Zumindest mit dem, was da jetzt auf unserem Zettel steht. Vielleicht haben wir ja was vergessen. Wenn ihr was vergessen habt, anrufen. Wenn wir was vergessen haben.
0 3 3 1 70 97 110.
Aber Google, bei Google waren wir stehen geblieben. Private Firmen hatten wir noch auf der Liste. Wie böse ist Google? Wie gefährlich ist Google? Und also Street View halte ich für ein vergleichsweise geringes Problem. Der Staat verkauft auch Daten von, also wenn man irgendwie das Häuschen nicht von vorne, sondern von oben angucken will, kann man sich von unserem Staat für viel Geld eine CD kaufen, wo ganz Deutschland hochauflösend von oben drauf ist. Die sind auch Datendealer. Es gibt aber Sachen, die sind bedenklicher als Street View bei Google. Wo wir bei der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte waren. Google Health zum Beispiel. Es ist so, dass irgendwie so schlecht und unausgereift diese elektronische Gesundheitskarte ist. Google Health ist noch schlimmer. Und Google hat auch mittlerweile, also die betreiben unsere DNS-Server, da hat jeder seinen Mail-Account und die Suchmaschine. Und die Menge der Daten, die bei Google liegt, ist schon ganz schön erheblich groß. Ich sehe momentan bei dieser Street View-Geschichte so ein bisschen das Phänomen, dass da auch Aktionismus auf Regierungsseite betrieben wird nach dem Motto, guckt mal, die anderen sind auch böse. Oder ne, guckt mal, die anderen sind viel böse als wir oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Google hat natürlich dieses Potenzial. Die haben mehr Daten als der Staat, ganz klarer Fall.
Und können auch flexibler ihre Ressourcen drauf werfen?
Jaja, die haben auch die Algorithmen, um mit den Daten was zu machen.
Also sollte man auch gegen Google demonstrieren? Oder Facebook oder wie beliebig andere große Firma?
Ich finde, man sollte zumindest das Problem thematisieren, wie man damit umgehen will. Gegen Google ist mir auch schon wieder zu plump. Die Suchmaschine funktioniert ja ganz gut.
Müssen wir nicht vor allen Dingen auch gegen die User demonstrieren, die da einfach ihr Zeug alles reinwerfen?
Vermutlich auch.
Am 11. September habt ihr die einmalige Chance gegen euch selbst zu demonstrieren.
Ich erinnere mich an die guten alten Zeiten im Internet, TM. Als man Internetzugang im Wesentlichen hatte, als man Student war, da gab es immer den Oktober, wo die Erstsemester an die Unis gekommen sind. Dann war es ein Monat lang schlimmer im Internet. Und dann waren die ausreichend weit erzogen, dass es alles wieder in Ordnung war. Und dann kam der Oktober, der nie endete. Das war 1993, als GMX online ging. Und aus der Zeit gibt es ein T-Shirt, wo drauf steht, The Internet is full.
Vielleicht könnte man das dann auch auf eine Demo tragen. Find ich gar nicht so schlecht die Idee. Eric!
Oh, hallo.
Guten Tag. Du kommst aus?
Köln. Also ich wohne gerade hier.
Wie? Was nochmal?
Ich komme aus Köln. Also ich wohne da gerade.
Du wohnst gerade in Köln. Und am 11. September wirst du wo sein?
Na, ich werde dann nicht nach Berlin fahren, deswegen. Also allein, aber... Also ich war bei der ersten Demo war ich noch da. Ja, also ich komme eigentlich aus Dresden irgendwie. Und ich kannte irgendwie niemanden, der mit mir dahin gefahren ist. Und ich war beim ersten Mal noch dahin gefahren. Und dann beim zweiten, dritten Mal, nach der relativ frustrierenden Erfahrung der ersten Demo, irgendwie war es mir dann den Aufwand nicht mehr wert.
Wie frustrierende Erfahrung inwiefern?
Na ja, ich meine, das war ja unglaublich. War schon irgendwie geil. Also die erste Demo, da waren glaube ich so 20.000 oder 15.000 bis 20.000, so was in der Dreh. Das war 2007, oder?
Kommt noch mal an, welche erste Demo du meinst, aber wahrscheinlich ja.
Ja, Freiheit statt Angst-Demo, die große. Ich glaube, das war 2007. Jedenfalls, die ist ja so massiv angegriffen worden von der Polizei, dass zumindest ein Teil sich einfach vorzeitig aufgelöst hat, weil es einfach nicht mehr weiterging, weil alle ein paar Minuten da die Wunderschaften da reingerockt sind.
Da erinnere ich mich dran, ja, da gab es irgendwie. Dann vermiete sich so ein bisschen das, was man vielleicht als protoschwarzen Block bezeichnen könnte. Und ich muss bis heute sagen, Hut ab von den Leuten, die damals die Entscheidung getroffen haben, zu sagen, wir brechen jetzt unsere Demo-Teilnahme ab. Weil wenn die weiter hier reinprümeln, ich hab das gesehen, die sind dann immer in zwei Teams reingelaufen. Die großen Flaschen Tränengas im Anschlag und haben sich dann den einen rausgesucht, wo sie der Meinung waren, der war ein bisschen zu doll vermummt. Und den müssen sie jetzt mal festnehmen. Und das ist irgendwie die gesamte Demoroute. Und da lief auch immer links und rechts ein Polizeispalier daneben. Das war schon in keinster Weise erfreulich.
Jaja, aber abgesehen davon, dass das schon echt ätzend war, also das war wirklich zum ersten Mal, dass ich tatsächlich einfach die Knüppel abfliegen sehen. Das habe ich noch nie erlebt vorher. Aber davon abgesehen war es oft der Demorote, man hat das Gefühl, boah geil, da waren einfach so unendlich viele Menschen und keine Ahnung, wo sich das dann aufgelöst hat, man hat das Gefühl, die hört gar nicht auf. Und dann kamen immer mehr Massen und man dachte so, boah jetzt bewegt sich was, das ist ja immer dieses erhebende Gefühl, wenn man in so riesen Demos drin ist. Und dann ist aber halt einfach gar nichts passiert und ja, keine Ahnung. Und ich glaube einfach, das Problem an der Sache, ich habe das ja schon eurem Redakteur menschenlang gesagt, dass irgendwie die die Gesetze machen, die jugt das halt irgendwie null, wenn da...
Oh, ich glaube, ich glaube, das ist zu falsch.
30.000, 40.000 auf die Straße gehen, das können die einfach geflegt ignorieren, weil es ist halt, keine Ahnung...
Ich erzähl dir noch so eine Geschichte. Also diese Demo 2007, die war schon ganz wesentlich, einfach für die Leute, die da waren, um zu sehen, ich bin hier nicht alleine mit meinen Befürchtungen, ich bin hier nicht allein mit meinen Ängsten und es gibt noch mehr, die der Meinung sind, sie müssten was tun. Und unter anderem ist ja die Gründung, ne, die Piratenpartei gab's schon, sie hat aber dann enormen Zulauf bekommen, auch in den Jahren danach. Und es ist mittlerweile ein Punkt erreicht gewesen, wo die etablierten Parteien vor der Piratenpartei tatsächlich zittern. Ich hab mit hochrangigen CDU-Leuten geredet, die mir gesagt haben, so irgendwie, wir haben ja auf unseren Wahlkampfveranstaltungen alles, da kommen irgendwie die Marxisten-Leninisten und da kommen die Nazis und da kommen alle möglichen Leute, religiöse Spinner. Und die Piraten waren die ersten, die auf jeder einzelnen unserer Wahlkampfveranstaltungen waren. Die haben unglaublich Schiss vor der Kampagnenfähigkeit, die das Internet mit sich gebracht hat. Die organisiert halt einfach irgendwie jedes einzelne Mal, wenn, keine Ahnung, Herr Schäuble geredet hat, war da jemand da und hat irgendwie Flyer verteilt oder Plakat hochgehalten. Immer, immer, immer. Und das ist es, wovor sie Angst haben. Nicht die 40.000 Leute auf der Straße. Das war im 17. Jahrhundert, als man mit einer Million Leute auf die Straße gehen konnte und dann einfach mal die Armee überrannt hat. Zeiten sind vorbei. Sondern worum es heute geht, ist, die entsprechende Entschlossenheit zeigen und die Organisiertheit und die Kampagnenfähigkeit auch politisch was zu erreichen. Guck dir an, was passiert ist. Die FDP lässt uns gerade ein bisschen hängen. Die sind auf dem Ticket im Bundestag eingezogen. Aber immerhin ist Schäuble jetzt Finanzminister. Ich finde, er ist da viel besser qualifiziert. Kann man das lieber vorstellen? H-Neu, du kriegst Keu-Nachtrag, schau es halt. Viel besser als Innenminister. Und da ist schon... Zumindest können sie uns nicht mehr ignorieren. Und das ist auch ein Resultat dieser ersten Demo von 2007 und den danach folgenden Demos.
Außerdem ist es unglaublich schön, auf so einer Demo zu sehen, dass man nicht alleine ist. Und dass da ganz viele Leute sind, die genauso ähnliche Interessen haben und da mal neue Leute kennenzulernen und so weiter.
Ja, also das sag ich ja auch. Also das stimmt schon. Ich glaube nur, dass es halt wichtig ist, vor allem erstmal einen Großteil der Bevölkerung aufzuklären. Es geht ja überhaupt ja nur darum, einfach diese bestimmte Unzumutbarkeit in dieser Überwachungsmaschine einfach abzuwehren, weil dieses einfach ein Staat so konditioniert ist, dass er natürlich auch gerne die Kontrolle über die Bürger haben möchte, so wie er halt aufgebaut ist. Aber man kann halt die schlimmsten Unzumutbarkeiten irgendwie abwenden. Aber dafür wäre es halt notwendig, auch einen größeren Teil der Bevölkerung irgendwie da zu sensibilisieren überhaupt. Erst mal das Thema, wie ich in persönlichen Gesprächen zuhauf mitbekommen hab, einfach egal ist. Also dieses dumme Argument, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen, was zwar so unendlich bescheuert ist, aber trotzdem irgendwie extrem wirkungsmächtig. Also ich hab so viele Leute, denen ich das erkläre, so bla, Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und ich find das nicht irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig. Und dann so, das ist mir doch egal, ich mach da nichts Schlimmes. Und ich glaube, wenn man dann so diese breiten Bevölkerungsschichten, also gerade die älteren irgendwie, die Piratenpartei, also erstens find ich die sowieso irgendwie nicht sonderlich sympathisch, aber die haben sowieso schon wahrscheinlich einfach demografiemäßig irgendwie ziemlich die Arschkarte gezogen. Aber wenn man halt auch viele, also so eine Großteil der Bevölkerung, dann kriegt man auch irgendwie wirklich einen, wenn man ein Wählerpotenzial hat irgendwie, dann glaube ich kann man da das da auch mehr erreichen. Aber das Schlimme ist halt nicht irgendwie, dass die im Bundestag irgendwie so stur sind, sondern dass es halt irgendwie ein Großteil der Mehrheitsgesellschaft irgendwie egal zu sein scheint.
Aber alles was du sagst, hört sich so an, dass es im Prinzip doch eine coole Idee wäre, zur Demo zu gehen, oder verstehe ich das falsch?
Ja, ja, sicher. Also ich sage nicht, es wäre keine coole Idee. Und würde ich in Berlin wohnen oder überhaupt in einem Umkreis, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall auch dahin gehen. Aber ich persönlich wäre das mir nicht antun. Ich finde das ja lustig.
Du redest ja mal einerseits, coole Idee eigentlich, man könnte es machen, aber ich werde es mir nicht antun, als ob das so ein Kratzeding ist, was man hinter sich bringen muss. Ganz entschieden bist du da aber auch nicht, oder?
Ja, also für mich was heißt Kratzeding, es geht ja nicht um die Demo an sich, sondern erst mal dahin zu kommen, keine Ahnung. Ich sehe für mich da jetzt keine Verpflichtung zur Konsequenz aus einem Gedanken. Ich weiß nicht, aber es ist gut, wenn Leute dahin gehen, die das können. Ich werde da jetzt nicht mit gelöhnt.
Du unterstützt uns moralisch und twitters drüber?
So ungefähr, ja wahrscheinlich.
Alles klar Erik, dann dabei viel Spaß. Das ist doch einer von den Leuten, wie es am Anfang jemand gesagt hatte, da sitzt man halt vor seinem Rechner und regt sich da darüber auch.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Abend Chaos Radio, weil letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Und Thema heute Freiheit statt Angst, eine Demonstration, die am 11. September stattfinden soll. Und dass der Chaos Computer Club will man erklären, warum man da hingehen soll. Wir haben so ein paar Dinge heute hier aufgetan. Also Vorratssaten-Speicherung spielt immer noch eine Rolle. Dann gibt es sowas wie die elektronische Gesundheitskarte. Dann haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, dass man auf der Demo gerne Sachen filmen soll, die nicht so geil sind, wenn sie von der Polizei veranstaltet werden. Und der CCC ruft ja auf, an dieser Demo mitzumachen. Und jetzt haben wir auch jemand am Telefon, der diese Demo mit organisiert, nämlich die Manuela. Wieso organisierst du so eine Demo mit? Also wie bist du überhaupt da rangekommen?
Ja, also an die Demo bin ich anders gekommen als an die Organisation. Ich hab mich auch letztes Jahr schon beteiligt an der Vorbereitung. Allerdings nicht so aktiv wie dieses Jahr. Ich bin inzwischen seit einiger Zeit, seit einem Jahr Mitglied der Piratenpartei und da in Berlin auch recht aktiv. Und da ich halt mit der Demo schon seit ein paar Jahren vertun habe, hat sich das so ergeben, dass ich in diesem Jahr auch die Koordination für die Piratenpartei mit noch ein paar anderen Rücken zusammen übernehme und da halt im Bündnis auch in der Vorbereitung recht aktiv bin.
Aber du bist sozusagen bei der Demo schon länger dabei.
Genau, am Anfang bin ich sozusagen intellektuell begleitend, Spiritüt gegangen und nicht hingegangen, weil ich dazu Bezeichen Baby hatte und ein Kleinkind und das wär dann irgendwie unfassend gewesen. Aber da war ich dann familial immer noch auf der Demo vertreten. Da ist dann mein nerdiger Mann hingegangen sozusagen. Und als die Kinder dann so weit waren, dass sie auch laufen konnten und verstanden haben, dass überwacht werden, wenn man in der Nase pupelt, vielleicht nicht so cool ist, haben sie sich dann entschieden, also letztes Jahr, ja okay, sie kommen mit. Allerdings standen wir dann doch sehr nah an den wenigen, das möchte ich auch mal dazu sagen, aber eben leider doch erfolgten Ausschreitungen. Und außerdem war die Bute letztes Jahr wegen Umleitung auch sehr lang, was die Kinder dann etwas langweilig fanden. Und deswegen werde ich dieses Jahr wohl eher ohne Kinder dann auf der Demo sein. Aber natürlich werde ich da sein.
Warum?
Weil es mir einfach unglaublich wichtig ist, nicht nur im Netz aktiv zu sein, politisch aktiv zu sein, nicht nur auf Veranstaltungen zu sein, die in Gebäuden stattfinden, nicht nur mit Leuten allgemein zu reden, sondern halt auch ganz klar für bestimmte Themen auf die Straße zu gehen und auch Leute dazu zu motivieren, das mindestens einmal im Jahr tatsächlich auch persönlich aktiv zu tun. Weil ich glaube, dass es einfach wichtig ist, dass man sich auch mal sieht, dass man auch nach außen zeigt, okay warte, bevor du weiter redest, du erklärst gerade sehr schön, warum es überhaupt lohnt, für eine Sache auf die Straße zu gehen, wenn man sich darum kümmert.
Die Frage, die ich dir aber stellen wollte, ist, warum findest du, dass es sich lohnt, um diese Sache zu kümmern?
Ich finde, dass es sich unglaublich lohnt, sich für Demokratie einzusetzen, dich für Freiheit einzusetzen und sich dafür einzusetzen, dass wir eine Chance haben, diese Demokratie, in der wir leben, weiterzuentwickeln, in einem positiven Sinne. Und ich glaube, dass viele der Dinge, die politisch aktuell laufen, schon seit langer Zeit laufen und im Moment sich dramatisch entwickeln, eben der Demokratie feindlich sind.
Was stört dich da am meisten?
Mich stört, dass ich immer mehr eingeschränkt werde, in meiner Freiheit mich zu bewegen, dass ich immer mehr vom Staat sozusagen in ein Profil quetscht werde, dass Daten von mir, von meiner Familie, von den Menschen, die mich umgeben, von uns allen in großen zentralen Datenbanken abgespeichert werden, die dann zum Teil zusammengeführt werden oder jedenfalls sehr eng beieinanderliegen. Da ist zum Beispiel diese Elena-Datenbank und die Gesundheitsdaten ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil die Firma, die da dahinter steht, als an einem großen Standort diese zwei Datenbanken haben, wird die dann nebeneinander liegen. Und das passiert natürlich überhaupt nicht. Und ich glaube, dass eine solche gläserne Gesellschaft, wo es aber einzelne Personen oder einzelne Institutionen gibt, die ein unglaubliches Machtpotenzial über diese einzelnen Menschen dann haben, dass das eine große Gefahr ist. Und dass die Menschen auch daran hindert, sich aktiv für die Demokratie und für ihre Freiheit einzusetzen, aus Angst heraus. Und genau dagegen möchte ich mich stellen. Ich möchte mich eben für die Freiheit einsetzen.
Und du wirst deswegen am 11. September auf der Demo mit dabei sein. Was ist dein Lieblings-Demospruch?
Ich finde eigentlich, dass in diesem Jahr Freiheit statt Angst gerade auch gegen das sprechende Datum sehr gut passt. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was es dieses Jahr sein wird. Letztes Jahr hatte ich keinen lauten Spruch, sondern bin ich selbst mit einer großen, gebauten Tab-Kamera und als Pippi Langstrumpf verkleidet auf der Demo gewesen. Weil ich dachte so, als das freieste Mädchen der Welt auf einer Demo zu sein, ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Allerdings haben das ziemlich viele Leute auch nicht verstanden und haben gedacht, oh, jetzt artet das Ganze in einem Love Parade aus. Aber okay, das war dann halt so. Da bin ich dieses Jahr noch am Überlegen. Wichtig da jetzt im Moment, als mir Demosprüche für den 11. September auszudenken, ist mir eigentlich Leute aktiv darauf hinzuweisen, dass diese Veranstaltung stattfindet und die, die es wissen, auch darauf hinzuweisen, dass man sich zum Beispiel im Aktionsbüro in der Hessischen Straße oder auch in der Pflugstraße im Büro der Piratenpartei Flyer abholen kann, Plakate, die man an seiner Lieblingskneipe aufhängen kann, abholen kann, dass man bei E-Mails, die man verschickt, einfach an den Fuß einen kleinen Reminder schicken kann, hey Leute, hängen kann, hey Leute, denkt dran, da ist die Demo, kommt hin. Also einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass überhaupt genug Leute mitbekommen, da wird diese Veranstaltung sein. Und ehrlich gesagt ist das auch mit einer der Gründe, weshalb ich mich heute angerufen habe, weil ich halt die, die jetzt zuhören motivieren möchte, selbst wenn sie nicht hingehen, zu gucken, wie kann ich es schaffen, dass mindestens ein, zwei Leute in meinem Umfeld davon erfahren und das auch wieder weitersagen.
Selbst wenn man selber nichts zur Demo gibt, sollte man sich wenigstens mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben, um dann eine bewusste Entscheidung zu treffen, ob man dahin geht oder nicht.
Das ist das eine. Ich glaube aber auch, dass wenn Leute sagen, ja sie können an dem Tag nicht kommen, weil dieses oder das ist, dann sollen sie halt jemanden schicken, der sie da vertritt und verwürdig.
Okay, vielleicht ist das auch eine neue Marktlücke, Demo-Vertreter.
Da gab es übrigens auch schon lustige Schilder auf den letzten zwei Demos zu genau diesem Thema. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau die Sprüche, aber so in der Art gab es schon Geschichten. Mir aber ernsthaft, also mir ist wirklich wichtig, dass die Leute wissen, hey wir können jetzt noch aktiv was dazu tun, dass einfach diese Themen wahrgenommen werden. Wir können nämlich über die Themen schreiben, reden, Mails verschicken, Leute anrufen, was auch immer und dabei auch zum Beispiel diese Veranstaltung.
Wie du es jetzt gerade reichhaltig getan hast, ich muss jetzt direkt mal Andreas und Nibbler vom Chaos Computer Club fragen, wollt ihr jetzt noch was anfügen oder machen wir die restlichen 50 Minuten Musik?
Ich glaube man kann zu dem Thema noch ganz viel sagen, also redet ruhig weiter.
Alles klar, danke Manuela, hat es erlaubt. Dann dir vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Demonstrieren.
Alles klar, bis dann.
So, man, das war ja schon mal ein sehr ausführliches Plädoyer, dafür zur Demo zu gehen und sich im Zeitungsfall vertreten zu lassen.
Das finde ich gut.
Wir haben ja aber hier immer noch die große Liste mit den ganz vielen Themen. Da steht ja auch der e-Paar drauf. Heißt der nicht mittlerweile anders?
Der heißt e-Paar, genau, e-Paar, neuer Personalausweis.
Können wir noch kurz zusammenfassen, was da drin ist, worum es da geht und warum wir den auf der Demo auch erwähnen?
Verschiedene Punkte, die da drin sind. Zum einen ein RFID-Chip, also ein drahtlos auslesbares Stückchen Elektronik wird Bestandteil des neuen Personalausweises sein. Dann biometrische Daten, also nachdem die Reisepässe jetzt schon biometrisch geworden sind, geht die biometrische Vollerfassung der Bevölkerung in die finale Phase. Jetzt kriegt jeder seine biometrische Erfassung. Das sind natürlich auch Probleme. Also in den 70er Jahren, als die ersten Vorschläge kamen, man könne ja eine Datenbank mit biometrischen Merkmalen anlegen, weil da gab es ja diese RF, das hat noch unglaubliche Proteststürme ausgelöst. Damals war das komplett unvorstellbar, dass irgendwie die komplette Bevölkerung erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wird. Und mit dem neuen Personalausweis wird das jetzt halt Realität.
Woher kommt das eigentlich? Was glaubst du, woran liegt das, dass dieser Protest so nachgelassen hat? Ist es den Leuten einfach egal oder haben sie erkannt, das ist gar nicht so schlimm?
Das ist eine spannende Frage. Vermutlich haben die meisten irgendwann aufgegeben, also zu sagen, nach 5 Jahren oder 10 Jahren oder 20 Jahren dagegen ist dann sowas wie, na gut, wenn es sein muss. Das denke ich steckt dahinter.
Wurde einem ja auch schmackhaft gemacht. Heißt ja nicht, dass man da für seinen Ausweis eine erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung, sondern legen sie mal den Finger hier auf den Sense und dann können sie mit ihrem Ausweis ganz viele tolle neue Dinge tun. So ist schon ein Unterschied, wie man das ganze labelt. Und da sind in letzter Zeit schon sehr häufig sehr vorsichtig umschrieben worden, was man meint. Und eben nicht gesagt, hier geht es um einmal Vollerfassung aller biometrischen Daten, sondern halt um angenehme Träume.
Gibt es auch ein paar Vorteile, man kann es dann online identifizieren.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch alles ganz ungefährlich, wie wir diese Woche gelernt haben. Und der Rüdiger hat angerufen, weil er auch was zum E-Pass sagen will.
Rüdiger, tach.
Ja, genau, ich habe letztes Mal mit ein paar Leuten darüber gesprochen, weil ich in einer gewissen Partei tätig bin. Und es ist ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass viele Länder gar keinen Personalausweis haben, da gibt es halt nur einen Reisepass. Es ist ja schon seltsam, dass wir natürlich beides brauchen in der BRD, dass wir dann auch diese ganzen überflüssigen Daten damit reinmachen sollen, obwohl die Technik ja noch nicht mal ausgereift ist, nur weil da irgendjemand sich profilieren möchte, so ähnlich wie die Riester-Rente, und da sein Name irgendwo steht, damit er sich so ein Ding mal setzt oder so. Genau, solche biometrischen Daten und sowas, ich weiß nicht, was das bringen soll. Das gibt es ja nicht möglich sein, außer dass man jetzt vielleicht dann meine Augeniris hat oder sowas in einer Art, und jederzeit mal kurz gucken kann, wer ich bin, oder dass ich meinen Ausweis zeige. Das kann ja nicht im Sinne des Erfinders, also doch bestimmt im Sinne des Erfinders, aber das hat ja nichts mit dem Schutz der Bevölkerung oder sonst irgendwas zu tun.
Würdest du denn deswegen zur Demo gehen?
Nicht nur.
Nicht nur, weswegen denn noch?
Generell halt, weil wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dann lernt man ja doch die Sachen kennen, dass das ein sehr, sehr langer Rattenschwanz ist und dass der Staat ja wirklich nicht nur so ein Projekt hat, wo er gerne mal ein bisschen mehr über uns wissen möchte, sondern ganz viele andere Sachen auch. Also Elena zum Beispiel, oder dieses Acta und dieses ganze Zeug, was total intransparent ist. Und das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Das war doch dieser Zusammenschluss, wo sich Nationen sich ganz transparenten Vertrag ausdenken, wie man gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu, wie man dagegen angehen kann. Das macht man natürlich alles geheim. Da darf auch nichts an die Öffentlichkeit geraten. Warum, weiß ich nicht. Aber irgendwie sind da ganz viele Nationen daran beteiligt. Und die wollen da halt wohl so einen internationalen Vertrag ausarbeiten, damit man diese schwerste aller Verbrechen besser behandeln kann.
Können wir gleich noch nicht mal versuchen, genauer zu beantworten. Rüdiger, wie wirst du zur Demo gehen? Also wie wird das bei dir aussehen?
Ich hab mich schon verabredet. Ich werde mit ein paar Leuten von einer Piratenpartei hingehen.
Jaja, aber wirst du dann sozusagen in Jeans und Parteiuniform? Oder ist dein Kurs transparent?
Ja, gehen wir schon ein Fähnchen und ein T-Shirt gleich anziehen. Also man weiß, wo ich hingehöre. Aber an sich hab ich mir gedacht, zu Elena könnte man eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes Wahlplakat machen. Man könnte sie ja zum Beispiel als eine Auskunftswillige Schlampe darstellen.
Wie genau soll das aussehen?
Vielleicht, wie sie gerade einem Politiker oral befriedigt oder sowas. Und er dann irgendwie sagt, ja bitte gib mir deine Daten oder so eine Art Sprechblase so darüber.
Als ich vorhin nach Elena gegoogelt habe, sind mir auch jede Menge leichtbekleidete Mädels positiv geworden.
Ja, das sieht mir auch richtig nach, oder? Alles mit Elster.
Mit was?
Mit Elster.
Was ist das?
Die elektronische Steuererklärung.
Aber mit Elstern will ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Okay, wir schweifen gerade ab. Rüdiger, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Plakatmalen. Das wird sicherlich lustig. Wir erwarten dann Fotos. So, so, dann wisst ihr also Bescheid. Um nochmal zurück zu Akta zu kommen, was genau, könntest du mal genauer erklären, was da passieren soll und warum man dagegen sein könnte oder vielleicht doch.
Akta ist, ich musste bloß gerade nochmal nachgucken wegen dem Herrn Schilli und seiner Involviertheit in die Bundesdruckerei. Und also ging es nicht um den Namen, da ging es um Geld. Da hat jemand viel Geld verdient mit der Bundesdruckerei GmbH, die mittlerweile wieder in Staatsbesitz ist. Akta ist natürlich ein Thema, da geht es erstmal um Urheberrecht. Das klingt erstmal so, als hätte es gar nichts mit Datenschutz zu tun, hat es aber wohl doch. Und zwar ist es so, dass die Urheberrechtsindustrie, die Musikindustrie, die Filmindustrie, die Verleger und ähnliche Konsorten ihre Freunde bedroht sehen im Internet und gerne die Knappheit physikalischer Güter, auch auf die Knappheit von eigentlich relativ leicht zu kopierenden Bits übertragen wollen. Und zu diesem Zwecke also ein sehr rigides Regime durchsetzen möchten, das verhindert, dass man rechte behaftete Bitmuster durch das Internet schiebt. Und die Mittel, die sie sich dazu vorstellen, sind also sehr weitreichend. Das läuft also darauf hinaus, dass die zum Beispiel einen Auskunftsanspruch haben wollen. Das heißt, ich als Rechteinhaber kann irgendwo hingehen und sagen, du hast da alles meins, sag mir mal wer das dahin getan hat. Und dann soll der Provider verpflichtet sein, die persönlichen Daten des Betreffenden rauszugeben. Also völlig vorbei an normalen Verfahren. Und auch für die Schwere des Verbrechens total unangemessen.
Das ist ungefähr so wie der Typ da drüben, das könnte ein Handtaschenräuber sein. Ich guck da mal eben in die Wohnung rein, ob meine Handtasche, die mir geraubt wurde, dort liegt.
Also Akda hat da noch mehr Aspekte. Da gibt es auch diese Geschichte, dass die den Leuten das Internet abklemmen wollen, wenn sie sich mehrfach haben mit urheberrechtsbehafteten Material erwischen lassen. Man kennt das aus Frankreich. Das ist dann vielleicht für das Thema Datenschutz und Freiheit statt Angst nicht mehr so relevant. Aber die Leute, die mit urheberrechtlich geschütztem Material Geld verdienen, die sind halt offensichtlich sehr einflussreich und schaffen es, internationale Verträge anzuleiern, die hinter verschlossenen Türen verhandelt werden, wo es im Endeffekt auch um unsere Daten, unsere Freiheit, sich im Internet zu bewegen geht.
Was hat es denn da mit den verschossenen Türen eigentlich an sich, weil du hast jetzt gerade viel davon erzählt, worum es geht. Was genau hat das mit der Geheimhaltung, die Rüdiger auch gerade schon erwähnt hat?
Die hat halt irgendwie streckenweise nicht ganz so gut funktioniert. Gelegentlich bekommt man halt mal Dokumente zugespielt aus diesem Prozess, was nichts daran ändert, dass man das meiste nicht weiß, dass die Verhandlungen hinter geschlossenen Türen laufen. Letzten Endes ist das so ein Ding, eigentlich wollten die fertig sein, bevor die Weltöffentlichkeit überhaupt irgendwas erfährt.
Das hat anscheinend nicht ganz so geklappt, ist aber auch gut, dann wissen wir übrigens, worüber wir dagegen, nee, wogegen wir da demonstrieren können. Das ist wieder so ein Thema, wo ich auch mal fragen würde, da wird immer gesagt, was ihr wollt, das wollen wir nicht so, dagegen, dagegen. Gibt es zu dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsdebatte da eine positive Lösung, die man auch mitnehmen könnte und aufs Plakat schreiben, so, hier, so machen wir das in Zukunft?
Also ich hab da mittlerweile eine sehr pragmatische Einstellung dazu. Und es gibt zwei Sorten von Leuten, die einen wollen, gehört, gelesen und gesehen werden und die wollen, dass ihr Content auch noch in 100 oder 200 Jahren verfügbar ist. Und dann gibt es Leute, die nehmen kurzfristig die Chance, vielleicht ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen, weil für die meisten Künstler ist es ja so eine Art Lottospiel. Man hat die 0, 1% Chance, die Millionen zu verdienen, die anderen darben eher. Dagegentauscht, dass man in 20 Jahren halt nicht mehr gehört wird, weil die Musik sicher nicht kopieren ließ und der Verlag, der die Keys für das DRM hat, der ist mittlerweile pleite. Also wer halt der Meinung ist, er möchte einen Althergebrachten Urheberrechtsmuster publizieren, der soll das tun und der ist dem Untergang geweiht.
Na ja gut, aber bis der Untergang stattfindet, ist es ja doch so, dass da irgendwie raufkopiert wird. Aber das gibt sozusagen ein Problem, wo es keine Lösung zu gibt.
Das ist ein... Na ja, das muss man wahrscheinlich gesamtgesellschaftlich lösen. Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei der Grundsicherung, weil wenn es Grundsicherung für alle gibt, dann gibt es auch Grundsicherung für Künstler. Und dann kann jeder, der der Meinung ist, er möchte Musik machen, sich mit seiner Gitarre in die Ecke setzen, Musik machen und irgendwie, wenn er schlecht ist, kriegt er halt weiter Grundsicherung, wie alle anderen auch, die nichts machen. Und wenn er ein bisschen besser ist, kriegt er vielleicht, wenn er in der Kneipe spielt, mal ein Bier spendiert. Bis hin zu wie viel hat YouTube jetzt verdient? Ich glaube 60 Millionen pro Nase auf ihrer Konzerttournee. Die haben überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, dass Leute ihre Musik kopieren, weil sie immer noch einen echten Arsch voller Kohle damit verdienen, dass sie einfach auf der Bühne stehen. Und da sehe ich halt auch eine Lösung. Das Tonträger kopieren war halt früher mal ein Geschäft, weil man mit physikalischen Datenträgern verbunden ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Dann muss man halt anders versuchen, die Künstler zu kompensieren. Und eine Kronensicherung wird helfen. Das betrifft dann auch Softwareautoren, das betrifft dann auch Journalisten, Blogger und so weiter und so fort.
Aber darum wird es bei der DEMO nicht gehen.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Das war jetzt nur ein Rand an der Seite. Ich sag doch, das ist größtenteils themenfremd.
Verstehe, verstehe. Es taucht auch, ich glaube auch in dem CCC-Aufruf, das Wort Post-Privacy-Spacken, glaube ich. Das ist kein wörtliches Zitat, aber so ungefähr in der Richtung wird da was gesagt. Was ist dieses komische Post-Privacy und warum würde es auf der DEMO unter Umständen eine Rolle spielen?
Post-Privacy ist die Philosophie und Überlegung, dass das mit dem Datenschutz eh alles hoffnungslos und zu spät vorbei ist und eh demnächst jeder alles über jeden weiß und so nach dem Motto Deal with it. Man muss damit klarkommen. Und ist natürlich...
Um es mal kurz zum Gehör zu bringen, ich hab's noch jetzt gefunden, auch alle, denen das Privacy is dead Gelaber aus der Industrie schon aus den Ohren kommt, dürfen mit kreativen Plakaten richtig beherzt dagegen protestieren. Privacy is dead Gelaber ist ja dann sozusagen dieses Post Privacy.
Ja, Mark Zuckerberg ist da glaube ich einer der größten Proponenten. Es ist kein Wunder, der verdient auch viel Geld mit den Daten seiner User. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch Leute, die sagen, es ist vorbei, es ist sinnlos. Und es gibt ja auch Kulturen, in denen das anders funktioniert als in Deutschland. Also es gibt ja einen sehr spezifischen Grund, warum gerade in Deutschland der Datenschutz zu hoch gehalten wird. Und das ist der, dass die Judenvernichtung im dritten Reich logistisch nur deswegen möglich war, weil auf Holorid-Lochkarten-Maschinen-Klammer-auf-später-IBM-Klammer-zu die Bevölkerung komplett erfasst und gezählt wurde. Und nach statistischen Merkmalen sortierbar war, die Kontenhaltenden zu dem Stapel Lochkarten greifen. Und suchen wir mal alle Juden raus, in folgendem Postleitzahlenbereich einstellen. Und dann konnten sie den Tropos schicken, der die abholt. Und diese Erinnerung ist eigentlich der Grund, warum gerade in Deutschland das mit dem Datenschutz so wichtig ist. Es gibt Kulturen, das ist ein bisschen anders. Wenn man in die skandinavischen Länder geht, da ist es völlig normal, dass man weiß, wie viel der Nachbar verdient, weil man kann ja so eine Steuererklärung auf der Website des Finanzamtes abrufen. Die haben da einen anderen Umgang mit.
Aber wäre das nicht auch bei uns in der Zeit, sagen da mal, so ein bisschen vorwärts geworden, das Ganze zu untersuchen?
Ich glaube, da ist auch die Gesellschaft noch nicht so weit. Weil was würde das in der Praxis bedeuten? Es gibt auch in Deutschland Entwicklungen, die dahingehen, dass man bestimmte Sachen nicht mehr verheimlichen muss. Vor 30 Jahren hatten wir doch einen großen Skandal, weil ein General der Bundeswehr seinen Job verloren hat, weil er schwul ist. Weil wenn er schwul ist, ist er ja durch ausländische Mächte erpressbar. Und sowas ist heutzutage komplett unvorstellbar. Das ist einfach vorbei. Damit, dass jemand schwul ist, ist das keine große Neuigkeit mehr. Er kommt wirklich irgendwo vom Dorf. Ähnlich war es mal eine Zeit lang anrüchig, wenn man bloß sich hat scheiden und wieder verheiraten lassen. Heutzutage steht in der Klatschspalte, Fußballer X oder Schauspieler Y hat neben seiner Freundin und seiner Geliebten noch eine Nebenfreundin. Und das interessiert auch keine Sau mehr. Aber das geht halt natürlich dann weiter. Ich versuche immer mal gerne als Gedankenexperiment mir vorzustellen, wenn ich in diesen Bundestag reingucke und sage, ich möchte jetzt Gesetz X oder Y durchsetzen, warum auch immer. Es ist ja nicht so schwer da die Keyplayer zu finden. Meine Theorie ist, dass wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele davon, keine Ahnung, Drogen konsumieren oder Prostituierte besuchen oder dann doch heimlich schwul sind oder eine Geliebte haben oder irgendwie, was sonst alles anrüchig ist, was Leute tun, was verboten ist, Steuern hinterziehen, wobei das so ziemlich der einzige Punkt ist, den ich moralisch nicht vertreten kann, dann kommt man so auf eine Mehrheit. Wir leben einfach in einer Gesellschaft, die auch ein Stück weit auf die Lüge aufgebaut ist, also auf die gegenseitige Übereinkunft, dass es halt bestimmte Dinge gibt, die gibt es halt nicht, über die redet man nicht, die macht aber trotzdem jeder. Wenn wir erst mal so weit sind, dass man da problemlos drüber reden kann und keine Repressalen zu befürchten hat, dann funktioniert vielleicht auch so eine Post-Privacy-Gesellschaft, aber vorher einfach nicht.
Man muss sich einfach mal vorstellen, man geht jetzt zum Bäcker und in dem Moment, wo man diesen Laden betritt, weiß man alles, was dieser Bäcker so in seiner Freizeit tut. Also 90% unseres Alltags beruht darauf, dass wir eben genau nicht wissen, was das gegenüber in seiner Komplexität an Persönlichkeit tut und ist und vertritt und so weiter, sondern beruht darauf, dass man sich in funktionaler Weise ergänzt, dass man jemanden wirklich in seiner Funktion sieht. Ich gehe jetzt zum Finanzamt und habe dann einen Finanzbeamten, mit dem ich irgendwie über Steuern rede. Und da interessiert einen das einfach auch gar nicht.
Aber vielleicht würde uns das unsere Gesellschaft viel menschlicher machen. Wenn wir alle von allem was wissen, man könnte sich immer mit Menschen unterhalten und nicht nur mit Funktionen, wäre das nicht großartig?
Das ist sicherlich in manchen Teilen eine attraktive Vision. Ich glaube, dass die Befürchtung, die viele Leute haben, ist, dass da einfach keine Symmetrie gibt, sondern dass da eine Macht-Asymmetrie entsteht. Dass es halt die wenigen gibt, die alles über alle wissen und die große ungewaschene Masse, die halt nichts über alles weiß. Aber vielleicht ist dem auch nicht so.
Das könnten wir vielleicht gleich noch mal ein bisschen vertiefen. Vorher machen wir aber Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's gleich noch eine halbe Stunde weiter mit dem Chaos Radio. Halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wo es heute um die Demo Freiheit statt Angst geht, die am 11. September stattfinden soll. Andreas und Nibbler vom Chaos Computer Club sind hier, um zu sagen, dass es doch eine gute Idee ist, dass man da hingehen kann. Oder habe ich das jetzt falsch verstanden die letzten anderthalb Stunden?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Nochmal ganz kurz, warum?
Wegen der guten Party. Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Unter vielen Leuten und überhaupt und...
Nochmal ganz kurze Zusammenfassung.
Es gibt ja da politische Dinge, die passieren sollen. Welche sind das?
Ne, die eben nicht passieren sollen. Oder anders passieren sollen.
Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist das wichtigste Beispiel. Und dann gibt es aber noch eine lange Liste von anderen Themen, die wir da haben. Wir haben Elena, die Arbeitnehmer-Daten-Erfassung. Wir haben das Akta-Abkommen, wo es darum geht, dass bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen die Daten der Internet-User rausgeben werden sollen. Wir haben den elektronischen Personalausweis. Klammerauf, holt euch noch schnell ein. Ihr habt noch zwei Monate Zeit, der danach wird auch teurer. Und ihr müsst so böse gucken auf den Bildklammer.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie lange habe ich Zeit meinen zu verlieren?
Bis Ende Oktober musst du den verloren haben. Gut. Wir haben die Volkszählung, die ansteht, also der Zensus.
Das hatten wir heute noch gar nicht. Da würde ich doch gleich mal gerne noch ein bisschen drauf rumhacken. Das verstehe ich nämlich immer noch nicht so richtig. Volkszählung, man zählt ja wie viele Leute da sind, das ist doch super.
Ja, und man erfasst alle ihre statistischen Merkmale und kennt dann jeden Einzelnen. Wie genau alle? Was geplant ist, da das mit der Volkszählung ja so einen schlechten Ruf hat, aus schon erläuterten Gründen, will man das nicht so machen, deswegen hat man sich jetzt auf das kleine Modell geeinigt. Das heißt, was passiert ist ein Registerdatenabgleich. Das heißt, die vielen Datenbanken, die vielen kleinen Datenbanken, die überall existieren, beim lokalen Einwohnermeldeamt, muss man ja sagen, das gibt es bislang noch nicht, das zentrale Register, wo alle Deutschen gespeichert sind, sondern man wird von seinem lokalen Einwohnermeldeamt verwaltet. Diese Daten sollen alle zusammengekippt werden mit den gesetzlichen Versicherungsdaten und was es da sonst noch alles gibt und einmal quer durchgerührt, um auch wirklich jeden zu erwischen und zu gucken, ob die Daten überall konsistent sind. Und zusätzlich dazu sollen Stichproben, auch wieder ein Anführungszeichen, befragt werden. Das sind, ich glaube, 10% der Bevölkerung, die dann einen Fragewogen bekommen, den sie gefälligst wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen haben, wo auch wieder dann Stichproben gemacht werden, ob sie denn wahrheitsgemäß ausgefüllt wurden mit entsprechenden Strafen, falls man es nicht wahrheitsgemäß ausfüllt.
Wie, wenn man bei einer Volksdefinition nicht mitmacht, wird man bestraft?
Jaja, das verboten dann nicht mitzumachen. Na, irgendwie ist halt nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit und kostet dich halt ein bisschen Geld. Also wenn du viel Geld hast, dann ist das nicht so ein Problem. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, diesen Fragebogen dann nicht auszufüllen.
Okay, das ist auch ein Thema, das auf der Demo vorkommen konnte. Tatsächlich hab ich gerade gesehen, in die Telefonanlage spinnt dann gerade ein bisschen. Hat gerade einen Carsten, glaub ich, angerufen, der uns sagen wollte, dass wir am Thema vorbei reden. Das ist natürlich die Gefahr, so ein bisschen, glaube ich, die entstehen kann, weil es umso viel geht mittlerweile bei der Demo. Oder gibt es ein, kann ich sagen, ein großes Thema? Also weil es scheint schon so, man fängt jetzt an zu sagen, ok, Datenschutz hängt irgendwie mit drin, aber es gibt da das und das und das und das und überhaupt, dann müssen wir mal gucken, dann müssen wir eine Kamera mitnehmen. Kann das nicht die Leute irgendwann dann auch überfordern? Also ist dann auch nicht die Gefahr, dass diese Demo genau zu so einem diffusen Happening verkommt, wo man hingeht, weil es ist halt irgendwie für eine gute Sache, aber eigentlich weiß keiner mehr so richtig genau, worum es geht?
Nachdem wir die Love Parade jetzt nicht mehr haben, ja?
Du böser, böser Mann. Boge, ich bin erschüttert. Nein, aber mal ehrlich.
Der Punkt ist halt auch, andere Aspekte der gleichen Thematik kennenzulernen auf dieser Demo. Vielleicht trägt man sich über das eine oder andere Gesetz auf, stellt dann aber fest, da gibt es ja noch das und das, was auch gerade überhaupt nicht gut läuft. Ich sehe das durchaus als Horizont erweitern und nicht als zerfasern.
Das widerspricht ja auch ein bisschen dem dezentralen Ansatz, den wir alle pflegen. Zu sagen, hier ist jetzt die Demo und das sind die von oben verordneten Demothemen für dieses Jahr. Wir haben dieses Jahr das Demomod und ihr müsst alle mitmachen. Sondern auch zu sagen, es ist hier ein Raum für Leute, die sich zu einem bestimmten Thema äußern können, was vielleicht auch die anderen, die das Thema Datenschutz, die das Thema persönliche Freiheit wichtig finden, mal wahrnehmen müssen, um das in die Debatte zu bringen.
Ich meine, das ist gar nicht so in Hinsicht zu sagen, dass jetzt ein Thema verordnet wird. Aber bei den ersten Demos gab es das große Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da war ganz klar, wo es hingeht. Und jetzt ist es so, okay, wir machen diese Demo, weil sie hat Tradition und wir machen sie auch in einem schönen, symbolischen Datum, 11. September, hatte so viel ausgelöst. Aber dieses Gefühl, es geht hier um eine Sache. Es könnte verloren gehen.
Ist nicht komplett von der Hand zu weisen, muss ich sagen. Und da muss man auch sagen, funktioniert die PR der Gegenseite oder die PsiOps schon deutlich besser. Durch den Entzug eines einfach polizierbaren Feindbildes ist es natürlich auch weniger leicht, Leute mit einfachen und klaren Argumenten zu motivieren, warum sie zu einer solchen Demo kommen sollen. Die Themen sind ja nicht vom Tisch. Sie sind bloß nicht mehr subplakativ darstellbar wie damals. Also das ist, glaube ich, das, was da passiert ist.
Könnte man vielleicht mal dann doch dazu übertreten, dass man so einen positiven Gegenentwurf der ganzen Sache startet? Oder wäre das zu viel für eine Demo?
Na ja, eine Demo ist eher eine Aktionsform, wo man sich jetzt nicht zusammensetzt und sagt, überlegen wir mal, was wir da tun können. Sondern das ist was Repräsentatives. Da gehen die Leute auf die Straße, die gegen oder für ein bestimmtes Konzept sind.
Aber das meine ich ja genau.
Dadurch, dass es so viele verschiedene Gruppen sind, die aber gemeinsam zumindest erkannt haben, dass es da eine Alternative braucht. Also ich glaube, das sind alles Probleme, die inhaltlich anders angegangen werden müssen.
Also das mit dem Dafür-Sein ist ja ganz einfach. Die Demo heißt ja schon Freiheit statt Angst. Die ist halt irgendwie für Freiheit und gegen Angst.
Das ist so der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Okay, darauf können wir uns einigen. Ich hab jetzt auf der Liste noch eine Sache, die wir hier noch nicht erwähnt haben, also sagen die viel mal kurz zwischendurch, aber haben wir noch nicht gesagt. Und das war Swift.
Swift, oh Swift ist ein ganz pikantes Thema. Auch wieder, weil die FDP sich an ihre Wahlversprechen nur sehr zaghaft erinnern konnte.
Okay, also reinfolge, was ist Swift? Das hat die FDP versprochen und wie ist der Stand?
Swift. Swift ist erstmal ein internationales Verfahren zum Geld durch die Gegend transportieren. Also sozusagen Überweisungen zwischen Banken finden per Swift statt, wenn es nicht noch regionale oder landesweite Netze gibt, aber wenn ich von hier ins Ausland überweise, dann läuft das in der Regel über Swift. Also erstmal so eine Art Bankengeldwechselstube, wo die ganzen Banken angeschlossen sind. Und die Amerikaner haben ein traditionelles Interesse an den europäischen Überweisungsdaten, und zwar auch wieder mit dem Argument der Terroraufklärung. Also es geht darum, zu gucken, wie finanzieren sich die Terroristen. Können wir die finden anhand der Geldbewegung. Was natürlich unausgesprochen auch immer ein bisschen dahinter steht, ist der Faktor Industrie-Spionage. Also wenn ich weiß, wie viel Firma A an Firma B überwiesen hat, nachdem ich weiß, dass sie ein bestimmtes Geschäft abgeschlossen haben, dann weiß ich wie der Preis war. Das steckt damit drin, da reden sie immer nicht drüber, offiziell geht es um Terroristen. Und die Amerikaner hatten lange Zeit Zugriff auf diese SWIFT-Daten, weil das Rechenzentrum dafür in den USA stand und die Leitungen eh an ihnen vorbeigelaufen sind. Und dann hat SWIFT irgendwann angefangen, das Rechenzentrum in die Schweiz zu verlagern und dann hatten sie plötzlich keine Daten mehr. Und dann sind die Amerikaner zur EU gelaufen, haben gesagt, irgendwie doch, gib uns doch mal die Daten. Und dann entbrannte sich tatsächlich, zur Abwechslung, mal ein Streit zwischen dem Parlament und der Kommission. Also Kommission hat natürlich gesagt, klar, könnt ihr die Daten haben hier, habt ihr. Und das Parlament hat gesagt, irgendwie, nee, wollen wir, sind wir dann doch nicht so. Und dann ging es hin und her. Und das Ende des Liedes ist, dass die Amerikaner die Daten jetzt tatsächlich offiziell bekommen. Also früher haben sie sich einfach genommen, jetzt bekommen sie von uns ausgehändigt.
Ich hatte gehofft, dass deine Argumentation noch ein bisschen länger ist, weil ich gerade einen Schluck Getränk im Mund hatte. Einmal Profis arbeiten hier. Also auch auf Gefahr hin, dass es jetzt 20 Minuten zu früh ist. Aber damit haben wir es oder gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir vergessen haben?
Ich hatte noch so ein paar Punkte, die ich erwähnen wollte. Also unter anderem irgendwie, weil es in den Nachrichten lief, das Arbeitnehmer-Datenschutz-Gesetz, was gerade frisch umstritten ist. Also was auch ein bisschen die Theorie widerlegt, dass die Öffentlichkeit sich nicht mehr nicht für Datenschutz interessieren würde. Datenschutz ist mittlerweile ein Thema, das ganz weit oben ist. Bei dem Arbeitnehmer-Datenschutz-Gesetz soll es darum gehen, dass bestimmte Sachen verboten werden sollen. So soll es zum Beispiel nicht mehr erlaubt sein, seiner Arbeitnehmer beim Pinkeln zu filmen. Wo man sich fragen muss, wie es war erlaubt.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, in der Tat.
Da hab ich auch gewundert, dass gesagt wurde, ja Wanzen und so weiter sind auch ab sofort nicht erlaubt.
Also es werden einige Sachen verboten, wo man sich einen Kopf fasst und fragt, warum ging das überhaupt je? Und auf der anderen Seite sollen aber andere Sachen erlaubt werden, die bislang verboten sind. Also die Deutsche Bahn ist ja in ihrem Datenschutzskandal darüber gestolpert, dass sie eine Rasterfahndung gegen ihre Mitarbeiter über ihre eigenen Datenbanken gemacht hat. Und das soll in Zukunft erlaubt sein. Und im Ausgleich dafür, dass man nicht mehr beim Pinkeln gefilmt werden darf, soll man jetzt mit öffentlich sichtbaren Kameras beim Arbeiten gefilmt werden dürfen. Ja, das verkaufen sie uns tatsächlich als Datenschutzverbesserung, dass man jetzt beim Arbeiten gefilmt werden darf.
Also ich finde, bei mir ist das okay, weil bei mir ist die Kamera eine Webcam, kann man auf fritz.de gucken, was der Markus so an seinem Pult macht, das finde ich auch in Ordnung. Aber so generell, wie sind Sie denn auf diese großartige Idee gekommen? Und warum demonstriert da keiner gegen?
Ich glaube, da sind tatsächlich einige Leute dagegen, also die Gewerkschaften finden das alles nicht besonders toll. Und die Arbeitgeberverbände finden das auch nicht toll, aber aus den gegenteiligen Gründen. Es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was, also wenn das Gesetz nicht bis dann noch beschlossen wird, auf der Demo Thema werden kann. Und dann hatte ich noch eine weitere Gesprächsthemenkarte, und zwar irgendwie Demo-Radgeber. Demo-Radgeber.
Also wie man, wenn man sagt, wir gehen jetzt davon aus, ihr geht dahin, wie man sich dort verhält.
Genau, weil da gibt es irgendwie so Spielregeln zu beachten, und es gibt diverse Demo-Radgeber, die empfehlenswert sind. Der CCC hat auch Demo-Grundregeln für Nerds rausgegeben, wo also das grundsätzliche Verhalten mal in eine nerdsugängliche Sprache übersetzt wurde. Ich kann ja mal ein bisschen auslesen. Jede Demonstration bekommt verschiedene Auflagen. Das sind die erweiterten ACL, wo auch die Route konfiguriert ist. Meistens ist die Route nicht nach Effizienz- oder Geschwindigkeitskriterien optimiert, soll im Gegenteil die Öffentlichkeitsexposures jedes Paketes maximieren. Auch erwähnenswert ist natürlich der Demo-Ratgeber der Roten Hilfe. Was tun, wenn es brennt? Sollte man mal reingucken, steht viel dazu drin, was denn die Rechte des Einzelnen sind, wenn man doch in Konflikt mit dem Team Grün gerät. Wobei ich ja immer noch der Hoffnung bin, dass wir es dieses Jahr mal hinbekommen, dass sowohl Team Schwarz als auch Team Grün sich an die Spielregeln halten.
Auf Twitter meinte gerade jemand, die Polizeigewerkschaft selber hätte ja auch dazu aufgerufen, an der Demo teilzunehmen.
Das finde ich gut, das muss ich mal sagen. Staatsbürger in Uniform sind Staatsbürger und haben dieselben Rechte und dieselben Interessen. Im Grunde genommen sind die meisten Leute, die in Uniform zu dieser Demo kommen, auf unserer Seite. Das Problem sind, wie immer, dass auch die eine Minderheit radikaler Spinner hat, die gerne mal die Langhaare geklatschen geht. Und genauso gibt es halt irgendwie Leute, die gerne mal irgendwie randale Demo, Steine werfen, habe ich Bock drauf, die sollen bitte auch zu Hause bleiben. Für uns ist jeder willkommen, der in dem Thema der Veranstaltung sich wiederfindet und der bereit ist, diese Aktionsform als solche zu akzeptieren, ob er eine schwarze oder eine grüne Uniform anhat.
Noch was? Oder war es das dann wirklich?
Ich glaube jetzt so ist es wirklich.
Hey, da haben wir noch genug Platz für Mike, der nämlich auf Twitter gelesen hat, dass es da einen Spendenaufruf gibt und jetzt nicht genau weiß, was er damit anfangen soll. Hallo Mike.
Hallo.
Ja, sag mal, was ist deine Frage zum Spendenaufruf auf Twitter?
Ja, ich wollte einfach mal wissen, warum kosten Demos diese Art für die Veranstalter so furchtbar viel Geld? Also, da soll irgendwie 2000 Euro über den Ladentisch gehen für diesen Einspendenaufruf. Und die Veranstalter reiten sich die Hände danach. Jetzt war meine Frage, warum?
Also Kosten hat so eine Demo auf jeden Fall eine Menge. Du musst alles mieten, was du hast an Bühne, was du brauchst zum Absperren. Du musst die Straßenreinigung hinterher bezahlen. Also da kommt schon alles zusammen Flyerdruck. Du musst vielleicht Leute durch die Gegend bewegen. Du hast Material. Du musst die Leute, die da irgendwie 10 oder 12 Stunden Helfer machen, vielleicht mit Essen versorgen. Also das läppert sich. Es ist nicht besonders viel Geld für eine Veranstaltung dieser Größe, aber so eine Veranstaltung kostet einfach Geld.
Stell dich das zufrieden, Mike, oder?
Ja, ich meine, viel mehr gibt es ja wohl nichts zu sagen, oder? Ich meine, wenn man schon mal so was veranstaltet hat, dann weiß man ja, wo die Posten hingehen. Im Prinzip hat man hier wohl nichts anderes als denselben Stress wie bei jeder anderen öffentlichen Veranstaltung auch, ne?
Genau so ist das. Also ich hoffe, dass die Leute mit den Finanzen zu tun haben, dann auch die entsprechenden Abrechnungen im Sinne der Transparenz, die wir ja auch immer fordern, so Transparenz und Datenschutz, was für ein wunderbares Gegensatzpaar. Aber ich glaube, im Fall von Mittelverwendung bei solchen Demonstrationen ist es angebracht, schon hinterher danach zu fragen, ob die auch ordentlich ausgegeben wurden. Wobei ich mir da auch relativ sicher sind, dass sie das werden. Also das machen schon Leute, denen man da vertrauen kann.
Mir wurde hier im Chat zur Sendung noch zugetragen, da meinte jemand, der Demo würden wohl noch 10.000 Euro fehlen. Und die Adresse, wo man sich das alles anlesen kann, wenn man ganz ganz ganz genau wissen will, ist freiheitstattangst.de. Ist ja ganz einfach zu merken, genauso wie die Demo heißt. freiheitstattangst.de. Mike, bist du zufriedengestellt? Würdest du auch zur Demo gehen?
Das weiß ich noch nicht. Da sind familiäre Hindernisse beziehungsweise Feiertage dazwischen.
Na wie, da geht ja einfach alle zusammen.
Mal schauen, wie das wird, ja.
Oder wenn du nicht kommst, schickst du jemanden als würdige Vertretung?
Ich werd auf jeden Fall mal rumfragen. Also ganz ungeschon, kommt so die Nördrige hier aus der Ecke nicht davon.
Na dann, viel Spaß.
Ja, euch auch noch.
Tschüss. So, dann haben wir noch eine sehr schicke Frage von Sarah zur Volkszählung. Sarah, hallo. Hallo. Was ist deine Frage zur Volkszählung?
Und zwar hat mein Cousin auch diesen Fragebogen bekommen. Und er möchte den eigentlich nicht ausfüllen. Jetzt stand in dem Brief allerdings, dass er sonst eine Strafe von 200 Euro bekommt. Und er möchte es nicht ausfüllen. Er ist auch noch in der Ausbildung und könnte dann die 200 Euro auch nicht zahlen.
Warum will er es nicht ausfüllen?
Weil er einfach keine Lust drauf hat. Weil es einfach zu viele Fragen sind. Fragen, die er auch nicht beantworten möchte.
Hast du da mal ein paar Beispiele? Weil ich habe so einen Fragebogen noch nie gesehen.
Ich kann ihn jetzt schnell holen. Ich habe ihn hier.
Ja, mach mal.
Das ist so ein richtig fettes Ding. Das ist echt übel. Und dann stand in dem Brief auch noch, wird einem richtig angedroht, wenn du das jetzt nicht auswillst, dann musst du 200 Euro bezahlen, als wenn man jetzt Staatsamt Nummer 1 wäre, weil man das jetzt nicht auswillst.
Hier Frage an die beiden anwesenden CCC-Leute. Da führt dann auch tatsächlich kein Weg vorbei. Entweder ausfüllen oder man zahlt es.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen, so sieht das aus. Es gibt natürlich immer noch den dritten Weg, sich einen guten Anwalt zu suchen und das mal von einem Gericht aus zu diskutieren. Aber der ist auf jeden Fall mit Kosten jenseits von 200 Euro verbunden.
Ich würde aber beinahe auch behaupten, dass es de facto noch die Möglichkeit gibt, dass eben hinreichend viele Leute diesen Fragebogen nicht ausfüllen, dass das für jenseits der nicht tragbar wird, da entsprechend gegen so viele Leute vorzugehen. Also da wäre eventuell schon interessant, sich da mal vielleicht zu organisieren.
Meine Oma hat jetzt angefangen, den auszufüllen und hat dann bei einigen Fragen wirklich, also hat die, keine Ahnung, erst in zwei Seiten dann irgendwelche Sachen angekreuzt und dann bei den einigen Fragen hingeschrieben, die dadurch, dass er eben noch in der Ausbildung ist und jetzt erst anfängt, nicht eindeutig beantworten kann, hingeschrieben so, ja, dass es schwerfällt, die Fragen zu beantworten.
Und hast du den Fragebogen jetzt zur Hand?
Ja.
Dann schlag doch mal, also erzähl doch mal, was da so drin steht.
Also man muss sämtliche Sachen bei seinen Wohnverhältnissen angeben. Also Miete und Größe werden noch bei einem wohnen, über Arbeitsplatz, was man da verdient, bis hin zu irgendwelchen, keine Ahnung, ob man verheiratet ist oder ledig, oder ob man Kinder hat, zur Arbeitssuche und Arbeitsplatzwechsel, ob man das in den nächsten Monaten vorhat oder ob man jetzt irgendwie umziehen möchte oder auswandern möchte oder sowas.
Okay, da steht also alles drin, das ist ja wirklich das komplette Programm. Gero hat auch gerade angerufen, will dazu was sagen. Hallo Gero.
Hi, ja ich wollte nur kurz nachhaken, dass dieser Fragewogen, der da ist, jetzt nicht die Volkszählung selbst ist, sondern der sogenannte Mikrozensus, den es schon ziemlich lange gibt und mit der Volkszählung, die jetzt nächstes Jahr ansteht, ja eher bedingt was zu tun hat.
Das hatte ich jetzt aber hier anders verstanden. Das war es doch so, dass beides zusammengehört oder nicht?
Ja schon, aber der Mikrozensus als solches, also den gibt es halt immer, also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie explizit zu dieser Volkszählung, sondern jedes Jahr gibt es einfach so eine Fragewogen.
Und du findest das okay?
Nein, finde ich nicht. Weil ich auch finde, dass das eigentlich nirgends zusammengehalten werden sollte. Also weil ich da finde auch, dass einfach viele Sachen sind, die eigentlich niemandem was angehen, außer allenfalls mich selbst. Also mich definitiv, aber alle anderen.
Hast du so ein Ding auch schon mal bekommen?
Nee, habe ich glücklicherweise noch nicht.
Woher weißt du das so genau, woher kennst du dich damit aus?
Ich bin auch zum einen in der Demo-Orga aktiv und habe mich auch der Volksfehlung ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Wenn du bei der Demo-Orga aktiv bist, da hat gerade jemand angerufen und wollte mal ganz genau wissen, wofür braucht er denn eigentlich so viel Kohle?
Genau, da habe ich auch schon überlegt, ob ich dann auch anrufe. Wurde eigentlich schon ganz gut erklärt. Es ist gerade sowas wie die Bühne, wobei da haben wir diesmal glaube ich ziemlich Glück, die werden wir relativ günstig kriegen, aber eben sowas wie die Flyer, die Plakate, die wir irgendwie gedruckt haben, die richtig Geld kosten. Eben die Versorgung, die Toiletten, die irgendwie hinter der Bühne noch stehen müssen, da halt insgesamt für die Leute, die irgendwie da sind, für Absperrvorrichtungen, für alles, was so irgendwie zusammenkommt.
Kostet denn diese Demo auch sozusagen Gebühren im Sinne von Anmeldungen oder Polizeieinsatz oder sowas?
Muss ich jetzt gerade passen.
Meines Wissens zahlt das der Staat. Also die Anwesenheit von Team Grün ist steuerfinanziert.
Genau, ich meine, dafür müssten wir nichts zahlen. Werden wir jedenfalls jetzt neu.
Und die andere Frage, die hier aufgekommen ist, ist, ob man das irgendwo nach der Demo nachgucken kann, was wofür ausgegeben ist und wie die Spenden verwendet wurden.
Also intern machen wir das schon. Ob das irgendwie öffentlich wird, weiß ich nicht, weil viele der Bündnispartner einen expliziten Teil bezahlt haben. Also da hat jetzt Organisation X irgendwie unsere Flyer bezahlt und Organisation Y eben irgendwie einen Teil für die Bühne bezahlt oder wie auch immer. Dass das im Nachhinein öffentlich gemacht wird, wer quasi was bezahlt hat, das glaube ich nicht. Also wie viel es insgesamt gekostet hat, das kann sein.
Aber zumindest wofür die Spenden verwendet worden sind.
Dass man das im Nachhinein irgendwie nachgucken kann.
Na das wäre schon schick. Gero, vielen Dank erstmal. Sehr gut, gleich noch Hausaufgaben bekommen. Sarah. Sarah? Bist du noch da? Du bist noch da. Das heißt also die einzige Chance, die tatsächlich besteht, um nochmal kurz zurückzukommen, ist Organisation. Also sagen, mit mehreren Leuten zusammen tun und dann versuchen richtig dick Alarm zu machen.
Wie viele Seiten sind das denn?
Ähm, viele. Also es sind irgendwie 53 Seiten oder so und hinten dran ist aber nochmal so eine Belehrung. Was passiert, wenn man das jetzt nicht ausfüllt und auf welcher Rechtsgrundlage das alles passiert? Aber einige Fragen sind auch freiwillig und dann sind wieder so Fragen, die man überspringen kann.
Steht da auch was passiert, wenn man das nicht wahrheitsgemäß ausfüllt?
Das hab ich jetzt, ich hab's nur ehrlich gesagt nur über Aflogen und ich hab nur gesehen, da war noch ein Schreibenbeiderstand wirklich einfach nur drinnen, wenn man das nicht ausfüllt und zurückschickt, kriegt man einfach eine Strafe von 200 Euro.
Ich denke, das wäre ein Punkt, wo man nochmal nachgucken kann, weil irgendwie das, wenn, also es kann ja vielleicht sein, dass da irgendwo steht, ja sie sind verpflichtet, das wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen, wenn aber die damit keine Strafandrohungen verbunden ist, dann zwingt einen ja keiner, das wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen. Also da kann man auch irgendwie, wie früher bei den Rollen spielen, da nimmt man sich halt einen Würfel und würfelt sich seinen Census-Charakter zusammen.
Ja, mal abgesehen davon wissen die ja gar nicht, ob es stimmt, also sie wollen jetzt überprüfen.
Ich denke, das ist nämlich das, wo das mit dem Census und dem Registerabgleich reinkommt, weil dann gucken sie nach, ob das wahrheitsgemäß ausgefüllt ist. Das ist noch der Mikro-Census, also noch sozusagen ein Fünfundzeichen alte. Wahrscheinlich kannst du die mal prüfen, guck lieber nochmal genau nach, aber das wäre sozusagen mein Tipp, mal zu gucken, was einem passiert, wenn man da einfach irgendwas ankreuzt und dann halt irgendwas anzukreuzen. Symmetrische Muster machen sich auch immer gut.
Mich würde echt mal interessieren, was in diesem Ding drin steht. Also kann man das sich irgendwie mal online stellen oder sowas?
Ich könnte mir jetzt die Mühe machen und 51 Seiten einscannen und online stellen, wenn du das möchtest.
Ist das verboten? Also ich will jetzt gerade sagen, ich will jetzt niemand irgendwie... Gibt es dann wieder diese Urheberrechts-Dinge, wo man dann Leuten ein Schnippchen schlagen kann oder sowas? Oder könnte man das machen?
Ist der schon zu Teil ausgefüllt, also sind da schon Fehler voreingefüllt oder ist das komplett blank zum Ausfüllen?
Das ist komplett blank zum Ausfüllen, zum Ankreuzen.
Und ihr habt auch noch nichts eingetragen?
Doch, meine Oma hat ein paar Sachen angekreupt.
Okay, dann lassen wir das mit dem online stellen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das ist nicht viel, das sind nur so unwichtige Sachen, die sind sie männlich, weiblich und dann haben sie Geburtstag.
Das muss dann echt nicht sein.
Das kann man dann verdecken.
Stichprobe, da, hier. Okay, es gibt diesen Mikro-Census-Fragebogen online im Bus nicht.
Ach gut, super. Hätten wir das wenigstens erklärt. Sarah, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für den Anruf und ich hoffe, ihr tut euch das zusammen und passiert irgendwas.
Dann kann ich natürlich auch gleich mal nach den Rechtsgrundlagen gucken.
Was wäre eigentlich auch mein...
Okay, Leute...
.eine eigene Sendung.
Ja, das machen wir vielleicht ein andermal. Jetzt ist nämlich folgendes. Ich werde jetzt mal kurz den Tim rannehmen. Hallo, Tim. Tim, wo bist du?
Hallo? Hallo, hier.
Ah, so. Es ist jetzt drei vor zwölf. Du hast eine Frage zu Elena. Die Frage ist, warum hast du nicht von der Stunde angerufen?
Weil ich da noch so doof war und mit einem Freund telefoniert habe und leider nicht den Chaos Computer Club gehört habe, den ich mir morgen aber ganz definitiv als Podcast runterladen werde.
Sehr gut. Da hat der Tim das ganz richtig gemacht. Das könnt ihr nämlich auch machen. Auf Chaosradio.de oder Fritzee gibt es nämlich einen Podcast zu dieser Sendung. Aber die Frage zu Elena können wir nicht beantworten, weil jetzt warten schon wieder ein bisschen Smart, die ihre Sendung umbenannt haben. Die heißt jetzt nicht mehr Night Flight, die heißt jetzt Musikmaschine. Oder Musikmaschine Night Flight oder irgendwas zusammen. Auf jeden Fall wollen sie es euch von der bedreckig bis stilvoll und elegant geben. Also der bedreckig kann ich mir bei Smart echt gut vorstellen, aber stilvoll und elegant, ich weiß nicht, wie die das hinkriegen wollen. Aber das könnt ihr dann gleich mal gucken. So, wir haben heute über die Freiheit statt Angst Demo gesprochen mit Nibler und Andreas vom Chaos Computer Club. Es gab viele Gründe, warum man da hingehen sollte. Werdet ihr da hingehen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Na klar.
Wie werdet ihr aussehen?
Ich glaube, ich werde Fahrrad fahren.
Ich werde mein Longboard mitnehmen.
Und so klamottenmäßig?
Ja, auch.
Mit Klamotten? Mit Klamotten. Also mit Kamera und Klamotten. Könntet ihr beide wahrscheinlich auch auf der Demo sehen. Den Podcast und alle Infos gibt es wie gesagt auf chaosradio.de und diese Sendung könnt ihr also dann genau wieder in einem Monat hören. Wenn jetzt noch ein Song, der ausnahmsweise keine Creative Commons Musik ist, den Herr Nibler hier angeschleppt hat, kannst du kurz erklären, was das ist und warum wir es jetzt hören.
Es ist für Raute Chaos Radio.
Na dann, viel Spaß und gute Nacht euch noch.